Houston it's been a year and a half
since our last interview yeah you're now
okay we're back at La film school yep in
Hollywood a beautiful place by the way
and you've lent us this conference room
and we have three of your students is
that right yes you're with us
yes rod Kyle and Mac great know if we
can we will be having questions from
them so for any of the viewers listening
or any of the listeners sorry that you
may be hearing alternate voices which
are not Houston or myself so that's what
this is and we also have a music class
in the back is that working so we may be
hearing a synthesizer - yeah so you
never know what you're gonna get what's
very cool and I wish I wish people could
appreciate this view by the way - so
that's great it's beautiful here
so your your book here is you're gonna
need a bigger story you know and that is
some of the old book or just an offshoot
of make your story really stinking big
when I when I started the write that the
new book is really just meant to be an
updated version of the first book thank
your story really singing big but once I
started writing it I ended up adding
probably 80% new content to it just
because within the two years since the
first book was released so much so much
of the industry changed so much a
technology change so much a culture
change just within that two year period
that the new content that needed to be
addressed was it was was more than the
old content so so pretty much ended up
being an entirely new book with about
20% overlap I know we've been talking a
lot about transmedia what about the word
super story can you define what super
story is and how does a differentiate
from a regular story so one one
interesting thing about the transmedia
space is is just the the word transmedia
and within the transmedia space even a
lot of people debate whether it's even
good to use the term transmedia people
don't know what the word is seems like a
clunky term if they if they do have the
if they have heard the word they if
there's a misconception around exactly
what it is and so there there's always a
debate of whether you use the term
whether you don't use the term it's very
inside baseball niche jargon industry
term
that sort of common people laymen don't
know or understand and so when I
released the the new book the I wanted
to try to find some sort of jargon that
was seemed less technical and so I went
with super story rather than just just
transmedia and super super story simply
meaning super being something that
encompasses a multitude of things so is
something bigger and so when you're
engaging in a transmedia philosophy you
are naturally increasing the size of
your IP and increasing the size of the
story so so that is that's where the
super story term came from there's that
there's a term within transmedia called
hyper diet Jesus which is a big ten
dollar transmedia word that specifically
refers to world building and if you
break that word apart hyper means super
and diet Jesus like diegetic means story
and so literally when you start to
engage in world building you're
necessarily by definition engaging in
building a super story something is much
bigger than just a single story you
spoke in the beginning about the rapid
change in the industry causing problems
I wanted to know if you think that
students should try to keep up to date
on things that they've previously
learned if by the time they graduate
it'll already be kind of evolved 100
percent everything changes so fast that
now it's incumbent upon all creators not
just students but but professionals
especially professionals that have been
in the industry a while you know the tip
of the typical you know thirty year
screenwriter that's you know seeing it
done at all they they find it difficult
to really want to stay on top of things
I think students naturally just because
the generation
they've got they've grown up
multi-platform and they naturally
learned all the new platforms and learn
all the new stuff but I think now we
live in
such an oversaturated crazy
technologically advanced time that
really if if you want to stay relevant
you need to figure out how to utilize
and maximize and leverage the new
platforms and the new the new touch
points of the methodology that audiences
are using every single day
and it's not necessarily because the
theater is going away or or Netflix is
is ensuring that everything streams it's
not necessarily that I always put it in
in reference to the audience and if you
understand your audience and you can
design to the audience
then you're gonna you're gonna you're
gonna be a better creator and if you
start to see audiences operating on
multi platforms as you start to see
audiences really gravitating today into
podcasts podcasts are very big they're
very popular today whereas two three
years ago not as much and but if you you
see a big push into podcast then all of
a sudden that should clue you in to not
just there's an opportunity on the
platform but to the mindset of the
audience and once you start to
understand the audience you will be able
to to take that psychology and lace it
through how you're going to create your
IP I think a lot of the new platforms
with with mobile with with with podcast
with you know like like Alexa you know
Alexa Google home you know all that
stuff I think understanding how that is
starting to shift culture why are people
using voice and why is voice coming back
it's almost like we're coming back to
like a 1930s radio area era again I
think instead of being instead of being
threatened by that that creators
screenwriters directors authors they
they should recognize that and use that
as an asset and a tool to be able to
leverage their IP into those things what
I typically get is well I don't know how
to make a podcast I don't know how to
make an Alexa skill I don't know how to
do any of that stuff and you know it's
like you can't teach old dogs new tricks
and I just don't believe that I there
you know I tell a lot of people there's
this there's this amazing website that
you can go to that teaches you how to do
anything in the world it's goog le com
you go there type in how to let make a
podcast how do I create an Alexis skill
how do I do something on IG TV and you
can spend 7 or 9 or 3 or 48 hours
reading and learning how to do all this
stuff and all of a sudden now you have a
you you have an extra tool on your
Batman belt as a screenwriter as a
producer as a director not necessarily
to replace your movie or your television
show but to be able to augment it in a
way that is is flowing in line with
culture and that I think is empowering
rather than threatening so I'm a big
advocate of never stop learning
especially as a creator because if you
never stop learning you're always going
to be in line with your audience
excellent anything else how do we differ
the how do we differentiate between
transmedia as like a marketing strategy
compared to like a storytelling
strategies should I be using transmedia
in my storytelling part of it or is it
just a marketing ploy
so I've historically bad transmedia has
been I think rooted in marketing and
what what happened nothing against
marketing marketing people great you
need good marketing marketing is not a
bad term it's not a pejorative term term
at all but where where transmedia breaks
down is when creators push the
transmedia off to the marketing people
that really don't understand the story
or really they don't have the right to
extend the story and so so a lot of
times you will see marketing marketing
heavy trends media pushes that are light
on story and it's more about you know
just trying to exploit a medium create
an entry point for an audience and there
isn't a valuable extension of the story
so so for me the best trends media comes
from flows through the Creator into all
these touch points to where now the
mobile game and the comic book and the
Facebook live and the IG TV series
whatever it is the podcast they're not
just marketing tools they're
storytelling tools and the big
difference is how much story your are
you getting or is it is it story first
or is it just promotional first the more
promotional it is the less valuable it
is to the audience I always like it it -
- you know I me my wife has two dogs we
love our dogs we're like weird dog
people that like love our dogs too much
and so I oh excuse me I always use the
analogy that you need to feed your
audience and feed your fans like you
feed your dogs and that that if that's
the first lesson you learn as a kid if
when you get a dog is that you need to
feed your dog every day it's your
responsibility that's what my dad told
me he said if what we're getting a dog
you're gonna take care of it it's your
responsibility to feed it every single
day
and and creators need to have that same
attitude when it comes to their to their
fans it's their responsibility to
continue to feed the fans it's don't
don't
Slough it off into a marketing person or
to a publicist or to other people - pas
and interns you need to now understand
this as a creator how do I feed the
audience which then begs the question
what's the best food to feed the
audience the best food to feed the
audience is story it's it's it's as a
Game of Thrones fan the best thing you
can you can feed me is Game of Thrones
story right not necessarily gaming from
its commercial or trailer I get excited
about those things but those are like
sugar rushes right so if you eat up if
you eat a bunch of sugar if you feed
your dog just sort of junk that may you
know if you feed it a treat it may get
excited but that's not going to nourish
them over the long term and so so the
thing that nourishes the audience the
most is just honest-to-god good story
and so if you if if you tell me as a
game of Thrones fan that there is great
story
delivered on Instagram I don't care that
it that it's Instagram I go there for
the story and I consume that story and
now there's a brand equity that that
continues to strengthen to me for the
the game of thrones brand in general
because they fed me and the more you
feed your audience the more loyal they
are right because I mean if you don't
feed your dog what happens they they
either die they go somewhere else for
food they turn on you and eat you like
Ramsay Bolton and Game of Thrones
reference but either any way you cut it
or or they they your neighbor who has
the food lures them away right and so
now in an oversaturated environment you
have all these people running around
saying hey come here I'll feed you over
here I'll feed you over here and now
there's more competition in the
marketplace and so and so for me the
thing that differentiates marketing and
transmedia is what kind of food are you
are you feeding your audience is it
story or is it just promotional and and
if the Creator is involved and it's part
of the creative vision it's more likely
than not will be more story than it is
promotional if as soon as the creator
disconnects and hands it off to the
digital marketing people then it they
may call it transmedia but it's probably
just gonna be a big marketing ploy my
question was how do we approach
transmedia as an independent filmmaker
a lot of us are working on very tight
budgets and low resources and having a
hard enough time just trying to create
our one story how do we approach
transmedia and should we be trying to
actually execute all these projects or
just develop them sure so this is this
is a question I get a lot is how does
this apply to the independent filmmaker
how does it apply to somebody who's not
Marvel or Star Wars or Harry Potter and
I think that why I love Star Wars and
Game of Thrones and Marvel and all the
big stuff I think this is more necessary
for the independent filmmaker than even
those big brands primarily because the
independent filmmakers don't
have the PNA budgets that that you know
large movies have and they don't have
the brand awareness that these large
brands already have and so if you're
independent independent filmmaker
operating on you know a hundred thousand
dollar feature a twenty thousand dollar
feature or doing something even more
shoestring the seven thousand dollar
feature you have to figure out every
single way possible to build audience
you have to figure out every single way
possible to compete in a marketplace
with with not just goliath like Star
Wars and Marvel but but everything
everything competes against everything
now and that's that's that what we're
getting with the where we are in this
entertainment landscape is it's
commoditized it's oversaturated and the
competition is just competition for
eyeballs and so what's really
interesting recently Netflix the CEO
Netflix said their biggest competition
isn't Amazon or Hulu or HBO their
biggest competition is fortnight and
their consists consistently losing to
fortnight which is the video game and so
so why do they say that it's because
fortnight even though it's in a
different industry necessarily from
video games to film or television is
just taking away eyeballs and so now
filmmakers today especially indie
filmmakers are competing not just
against the other films that are in the
market that that are in the festival
market or the films that are streaming
films that are in the theater they're
competing against the films that are in
the theatres the films that are
streaming every film ever made and
anything that's on TV and anything
that's on Apple music or Spotify and any
podcast that's on the podcast or any
video game on Steam on Xbox Playstation
on mobile you're competing against
YouTube you're competing against
Instagram you're competing in its
everything because everything is in
competition with everyone's up for a for
everyone's eyeballs you're just
competing for the attention of the
consumer or the audience attention is
the game that's the that's the that's
the thing that that everyone's fighting
for it you know again it's like the game
of Thrones
it's it's it's everybody's
for the Iron Throne in entertainment
everyone is fighting for the attention
of the audience and there's so many
things pulling attention now it's a it's
a it's a tougher fight and this this has
never been like this ever but today
Studios they they release films around
new videogame releases when the new Halo
video games going to drop the studio's
avoid that weekend because they know
anyone 18 to 30 is going to be playing
Halo all weekend they're not going to be
going to the box office
so all that to get back to saying if
you're the the small independent
producer that has a low budget you have
to figure out a way to compete you have
to figure out a way to survive to thrive
to exist in this market and it's tough
to out punch everybody you can't
overpower Star Wars you can't overpower
fortnight or any of these other things
now you have to be craftier right so you
can't just inundate the world with
marketing with with posters with
trailers you can't buy TV spots so what
can you do and so if you have a good
idea if you have a good story and you're
a great storyteller now there's all
these really interesting tools that we
can use to now send your story out and
capture the attention the audience right
and so it's not necessarily about
putting one fishing lure out there now
I'm now that we have so many tools we
can have ten or twelve fishing lures out
there simultaneously fishing in 12
different ponds all all the time looking
for audience and and so what I get
though is independent creators saying
one I don't know how to do it or even if
they know how to do it they say that
seems like a lot of work right and that
like that to me that is is such the
wrong mindset to have right because we
talked about this in the first round of
interviews we did is I always encourage
independent filmmakers to be thinking as
entrepreneurs rather than just an artist
and because when you're when you're
creating IP when you're creating when
you're launching a film you're launching
a small business you're you're setting
up an LLC you're
Staffing it with a crew and you're
creating something and you have to think
of yourself just like the guy who's open
in the coffee shop or the woman that's
opening the pizza shop or the family
that's opening of the candle store down
the street you have to have that same
mentality and so though like if you
understand the amount of hours and hard
work it is to launch your own business
then you you they independent filmmakers
understand it in context of a film
they're fine with spending 18 hours a
day on a film set for you know 12
straight days they that's fine because
that's they think that's just within the
context of what they do but now it's
broadened to where now you have to learn
how to you have to learn how to broaden
the scope of that to have a have a more
more skill sets at your disposal in
order to compete in this crazy market so
as a pizza shop owner can't say well I
love to make pizza that's my thing I'm
not gonna worry about the bookkeeping
because you know who cares about that
well I'm not gonna worry about you know
the front of the house I'm not gonna
worry about these other things all I'm
gonna do is make my pizza the business
owner the chef may but the business
owner has to concern themselves with
everything they have to know the full
scope of everything and they have to be
able to put in the hours and the work to
be able to figure that stuff out if they
want a successful business and even even
when they do that most small businesses
fail and they fail primarily either
because of lack of quality or they don't
figure those other things out right they
though they can't figure out how to
compete and so so it's such an audacious
thing to say you want to be a filmmaker
for the rest of your life this is your
dream and what you want to do is you
want to live your life professionally
making movies for the rest of your life
that is such a first world crazy dream
to have which is an awesome dream and
that that if it's in your heart 100% go
for it but you have to understand how
rare that is and how audacious that is
and the big disconnect within especially
independent filmmakers is they have this
audacious dream
of how they want to live the rest of
their life just making the movie like
their own movies and that's their job
forever they have this audacious dream
but at the same time don't want to go
the same audacious route to be able to
put in the work to learn all the stuff
you need to do to compete to do to make
that happen right and what they say to
me is they say well Tarantino didn't do
that
I mean Tarantino broke yeah and like you
know Beyonce doesn't do this or like a
point to they point to these people that
one broke in in a different era
first of all like we talked about how
fast things change now like things have
changed from 2019 like 2015 to 2019
completely different let alone when
Tarantino broken into the mid-90s right
like you it's not the same world it's
not the same thing and and the problem
that I think people have is they look at
Tarantino or they look at Scorsese they
look at these people score say she
doesn't do transmedia
I don't need to do transmedia right the
the problem of that is is you're not
Scorsese and it's I but kind of a tough
yet let me just say you're not Scorsese
yet you're not Tarantino yet right like
when I was a kid played baseball my dad
was my baseball coach and and when you
when you teach kids to play baseball you
teach them to catch a ball with two
hands
right you just catch a ball two hands to
the ball wouldn't pop out of your glove
right real simple thing my dad takes me
to a professional baseball game and I'm
watching King Griffey junior in the
outfield catching flyballs and he's
catching it with one hand he's catching
behind his back he's catching it like
sort of down by the ground he's doing
all these crazy things and I say dad you
tell me I have to catch with two hands
but king griffey jr. does not catch him
with two hands why can't I just catch
with one hand like him he and he looked
at me and said son if once you get to be
as good as ken griffey jr. and once you
make the major leagues you can do
anything you want
right and so but until then you catch it
with two hands right and so so right now
I think like independent filmmakers
should not map her actions based on the
super successful
cream-of-the-crop directors and
producers and writers I think that's a
mistake
as far as craft goes a hundred percent
map your actions after those people like
you can learn so much about film the
craft of filmmaking from Tarantino
obviously but I'm not just I'm not
talking about that because the creation
of the product is just one component of
what it takes to be successful in the
industry right so you have to have sort
of a collection of things sort of a line
that you need to put together to be able
to have a success YP to be able to have
a successful business if you mean
filmmakers know this you can make the
greatest movie in the world if you don't
know how to distribute it well no one
will see it you could be the greatest
writer in the world and write the
greatest script but if but if but if
your DP doesn't know what he's doing or
she's doing then the film comes out
poorly like you have like it takes more
than just your individual talent to be
able to pull this thing off and so when
it comes to craft map your actions with
the with the big folks but but at the
same time understand and be self aware
of where you are in your career and you
need to say you know what one day I can
be Tarantino one day I can be Scorsese
but I'm not now so what do I use what
can I use how do I use everything
possible in order to position myself in
a way that I can get there the path is
there right but the world is different
then when Steven Spielberg started
shooting movies it's just a different
world right and it's good to like read
about Steven Spielberg and the whole
thing but but but you can't say well
Steven Spielberg do this so I don't have
to do it or I can do it because he did
it or whatever right so it's just a
whole different thing so I'm very
bullish on the fact that independent
creators need a multi-platform
transmedia super story more than anybody
in order to compete and in order to be
able to make a splash in this
oversaturated world I don't think it's
just for the big guys yeah it's really I
mean Blair Witt I mean that's what play
rich did back I mean that was like sort
of that that blurring of reality and
fiction that
that I mean I saw Blair Witch the the
first day it was released and didn't
know what it was me and my girlfriend
now wife we were in college for the
freshmen in college and we we were
walking by an indie movie theater in
Cincinnati Ohio and we wonder watch the
movie was noon and we didn't know like
there was just an indie feeder we didn't
exactly know everything what the movies
were we said all the Blair Witch Project
that seems it had an interesting poster
and so we wouldn't watch that and you
know it's hard now in today's context to
really understand what what that movie
was like back then but found footage
wasn't a thing then it was like it like
we had never seen anything like that
before and we were debating during the
movie is this real is it not real like
it didn't seem scripted but at the same
time I liked like what that if this was
real would they put it in the movie
theater we were debating during the
movie after the movie we left we were
still debating it and we decided to go
to the Internet for the final arbiter of
you know what's real and what's not and
when we go to the Internet what do we
find we find a collection of news
broadcasts and police reports and all
this stuff that made it seem like it was
real and it was the whole you know Orson
Welles war the world's thing just you
know sort of fast warded to that you
know to the Lucas was late late 90s when
that was really 99 I think wasn't ruling
and so but but but it was the blurring
between the the fiction of reality for
like two weeks no one knew if it was
real or not and that's really that that
conversation that zeitgeist that it
created is what really made that film so
popular and then you know when that when
the people came out in the Video Music
Awards MTV MTV Video Music Awards then
you're like oh okay it's fake but for
two weeks they had everybody fooled they
well they didn't have people fooled they
just didn't know you know and that was
the conversation so so they were like
you know that and they were indie
filmmakers and you have to think back I
mean you know the budget of Blair was
super small
and and they they understood the power
they said we can't out punch Sony we
can't out punch Warner Brothers we can't
out punch these guys but what we can do
is we could leverage the assets of today
and the power of audience and the power
of the Internet to be able to create a
conversation to be able to create a
brand equity around the story that
ultimately ballooned the brand into
something that could out punch those
other those other folks at the box
office
super cool story right and now what's
cool today we have more tools more
opportunities to be able to do that as
independent filmmakers you know
especially especially when we maybe may
save this for a different question but
especially before financing right like
like you know trying to go out and get
the money that's transmedia can be a
huge asset for you when you when you go
to actually finance your film that if
you don't understand it then then you
know maybe you don't get financing at
all but but if you did understand it
maybe you get you get the financing we
get a larger block of the financing so
what are your favorite two or three
story worlds and what makes them so
special wow that's a dumpling that's
like yeah some people like their
favorite movies I I think I think you
know I'm a big I'm a big star Wars fan
and I have been since since I was a kid
and I think that the that the the thing
that made Star Wars outpace its
contemporaries is the story world and
it's interesting I always sort of put up
these two I just opposed to movies and
by saying in 1977 two movies were
released the same genre the same budget
the same target market the same
everything which was Close Encounters of
the Third Kind didn't Star Wars one did
really well and and had a good box
office returned another became a 60
billion dollar brand and what's the
difference I I think for me clearly
Steven Spielberg is the superior film
maker from a craft stamp
but what was it about Star Wars that
made it outpace you know close encounter
not just closing columns but everything
else and now you know obviously the
Disney it's still it's still growing and
I was reading a book that actually had
an interview with Steven Spielberg where
they asked him that same question they
said what for like why did Star Wars do
so much better
and he said there was two reasons he
said George always had a bigger vision
than just a single movie and I always
just saw Close Encounters as one thing
and he said too because he had that big
vision he created a world that people
wanted to explore he said I didn't even
consider my story wrote by doing Close
Encounters I was just focused on the
plot so George Lucas really created a
story world that people want to explore
and and and that's something that I
gravitated to as a kid and so I'm I'm I
you know I'm a fan I'm a fan of Star
Wars I'm a fan you know there's things
Game of Thrones and and Lord the Rings
fantasy worlds I'm a big fan of but but
recently I've been really interested in
story world that aren't sort of sci-fi
epics or fantasy epic sword and sandal
type stuff one tremendous story world
that I don't think gets enough credit is
Deadwood I think Deadwood has a
tremendous story world where where if if
you watch that would anybody's watch
Deadwood is you know that this the
physical geographic size of Deadwood is
not that big but it had such a robust
interesting collection of characters
that I thought that story world was
tremendous in its story potential and
I'm and I'm happy they're they're gonna
bring a feature film back to sort of cap
the whole thing off but but I always
just loved that story world specifically
another HBO show that I'm a big fan of
the story world is sharp objects and
that was a recent recent show with Amy
Adams
and I thought the story world of windgap
of where that story was set was such an
interesting cool weird creepy Midwest
town that I just thought that was like
tremendous so storyboards don't
necessarily have to be the sword and
sandal Game of Thrones Star Wars thing
doesn't have to be set in space they
don't have to you know have superheroes
than them story worlds are interesting
places that have great story potential
that's all a story world is is is if you
understand your story world you will
always understand your story potential
and great story worlds will continue or
have the potential of continually
creating stories over time and I can see
by looking at windgap by looking at
Deadwood by looking at Star Wars is you
can I I can see multiple stories whether
they may not have all be TV they may not
all be feature films but there's
something right and fans I've being a
sharp objects fan or being a deadwood
fan I don't care what platform they're
delivered in I don't care if it's as a
film or a television show if there's a
deadwood book I'll read it if there's a
deadwood game I'll play it if there's a
deadwood book of poetry I'll read it
because I like I like to play in that
world that's the sandbox and so just as
a fan those are those are Douglas a big
fan of Douglas Adams Hitchhiker's got to
be out see I think that's an underrated
story world as well but but those I
didn't give you two or three I gave you
like seven but but those are the things
that I leaned to be interesting to see
if Phil okay dick were still alive what
story worlds would have come from
historian sure because you could go so
many different places with it a hundred
percent and and one and it's really
interesting is for independent
filmmakers a lot of a lot of filmmaking
and financing and selling a script is is
you have to generate pre awareness you
have to have some sort of you know brand
awareness to be able to sell to the
studios or get something optioned and
that's you know is it based on the book
is it based on you know it's something
like that
that's what a lot of independent film
independent filmmakers and writers get
into is I write a script and it's great
but it has no brand awareness or no pre
awareness engineered so I no one will
pick it up no one option it there's a
lot of stuff in the public domain
especially in the sci-fi genre that have
tremendous story worlds including some
philip k dick stuff you know Isaac
Asimov had great story worlds most of
his stuff is in the public domain
Jules Verne had tremendous story worlds
and all of his stuff is in the public
domain The Wizard of Oz one of the
greatest story worlds of all time oz is
in the public domain which means anybody
any of us can do a Wizard of Oz project
Wizard of Oz project set in the story
world of The Wizard of Oz and so so
that's an interesting asset to be able
to identify the philip k dick stuff
isaac asimov stuff jules verne stuff
Wizard of Oz stuff and say here's the
sandbox I don't necessarily want to
retell The Wizard of Oz Dorothy story's
already told but the story world gives
me a sandbox in which to operate in
which to play I'll tell a completely
different story in there that is just
set in that world but then allows me to
use the pre awareness of Oz to be able
to leverage myself into a less risky
proposition to you know the the studio's
the networks or the agents that I want
to be able to send my stuff to I think
it's an underutilized asset of
understanding what's in the public
domain tremendous story worlds that are
there speaking of things that are in the
public domain
how would fanfiction factor into
transmedia fanfiction is a really
important part of of community building
because fans fans like to play in the
sandbox themselves and create strictly
definitionally the the fan fiction
doesn't necessarily connect into the
broader transmedia conversation it it
only because it's not canon and so when
we're talking about transmedia we're the
we're really talking about
how do you extend the story across
multiple platforms in a way that's
canonized and Canon just means official
right so that is this official Star Wars
stuff or not and if it's official Star
Wars stuff then then it's going to be a
trans mediated extension if it's not
it's just something it's something else
it's it's a valuable part of your
community building and as part of your
participatory culture as a creator
encouraging your fans to add in add
their stories in but for me as a fan
then this is where it matters for me as
a fan of any IP if I know something is
canon
then I will I'm more likely to check it
out because I know it's official but if
you just write your own short story
about Game of Thrones and it's not canon
I may check it out but I really have no
incentive to check it out
especially if I don't know you right so
so when we're talking about how do you
how do you create the migration of the
audience the migration of the audience
is generated based on canonization and
not and for example I was I've never
been a fan of Legos not just the not the
toys but like I don't particularly love
the Lego IP and like I didn't realize
I've just never been a huge fan of the
movie the song kind of irritates me I
step on Legos having a kid like there's
this Lego thing that I have so so don't
love Legos to the point that were even
though I love Star Wars
they had a Lego Star Wars cartoon that I
didn't watch and the reason I didn't
watch it and it isn't because I hated
Legos that it's something to do with it
but the Star Wars Legos cartoons weren't
canon they weren't it wrapped into the
continuity of the Star Wars universe and
so because I don't like Legos and this
wasn't Canon I didn't watch it I didn't
need to that wasn't part of the puzzle
for me but one day I see on Twitter that
said Lucasfilm says Star Wars Legos is
now part of the continuity
it's now part of cannon so the first the
first episode for example of the new
Star Wars Legos was will do you remember
in the force awakens in the force
awakens han and chewie they have the
raft ours on the ship and the big
monsters that they that the catch and
fin says to tahan he says you have Rath
doors on the ship how did you get raft
ours and han said well we used to have a
bigger crew and and then they move on
and they don't they don't reference it
anymore right first episode of Star Wars
Legos shows how Han and Chewie got the
raft ours right and it's cannon which
means it's real it's actually part of
the puzzle so I guess what I do despite
my hatred of Legos I go watch the
cartoon because I want that piece of the
puzzle the second episode of Star Wars
Legos if you remember back to the force
awakens Poe and Finn crash land on jakku
and finn wakes up doesn't know where Poe
is thinks he's dead and then we find Poe
at the end of the movie when they
reconnect for his pub in that entire
time second episode of Star Wars Legos
follows Poe one of the adventure that he
that he goes on after he wakes up from
the crash and it's canon therefore I am
now I have incentive to watch it now if
that had just been your short story or
our fan film or a fans made like the
little stop-motion lego things like they
do that's cool but me as another fan
have no incentive to check that out I
may applaud you and give you a thumbs up
and may you know but I don't necessarily
know if I'll take my time to do that so
so that's where the I'm not anti fan
fiction at all I think it's awesome for
creators to encourage fans to play in
their sandbox in a participatory way I
go so far as to say creators should
encourage them to play in the sandbox
and actually take the opportunity to
canonize certain parts of fan fiction
and that's as a way I love it's sort of
a contest way but as a way to validate
the fan base in a valuable way so so so
definitely I'm Pro fan fiction 100% but
definitionally when we're talking about
transmedia I consider it right outside
the door
just because of the canonization
question how do we as independent
filmmakers use transmedia to elevate our
production pitches or when we're trying
to take on investments or get financing
for our projects how do we use
transmedia to make that more easily
accessible so a question that I got
after the first round of film courage
interviews we had was a lot of people
asking me about how this impacts the the
the search for investment you know
independent filmmakers independent
creators are always looking for money
and that's just part and parcel you have
to figure out and pay the crew you have
to figure out how to you know pay for
the sets you have to buy insurance you
have to do all these things so so money
is is is necessary and so a lot of
people were out there trying to find a
private equity investment into their
film and right now that's that's very
difficult when you talk to any
independent filmmakers they're gonna say
the search for financing is one of the
most frustrating difficult things that
that you do as a film as a filmmaker and
and that's why a lot of people pivot to
things like Kickstarter or IndieGoGo
because they want to crowdsource that
and unfortunately most you know the vast
majority of things when Kickstarter the
the vast majority of films and
Kickstarter don't get funded at all and
on average films on Kickstarter get
funded at about $12,000 and and if and
if you're aged twelve thousand dollars
on Kickstarter to make a movie I am
rooting for you and hope you make the
greatest $12,000 movie you've ever made
but if you want to filmmaking to be your
career and you don't want to be you
don't want filmmaking to be your side
hustle then we have to figure out how to
how to get beyond the 12,000 dollar
movie and so a lot of my focus over the
past year and a half has been working
with independent creators on how to
better position their films for
investment private equity investment and
so because a lot of people a lot of
filmmakers think transmedia is for the
back end stuff it's it's after you make
your movie and how to you know how to
promote it or how to extend it or how to
expand it but but I think you need to
one
front-load you're transmedia plan before
you go out to get investment one if you
if while you're while you're writing
your script while you're shopping your
script while you're looking for
financing for your script you could be
extending your IP and building audience
the entire time mostly every writer that
I know when they when they write a
script they're hustling that thing for
two three four sometimes sometimes ten
years looking for investment or trying
to get it optioned and so if during that
time that you're developing hustling
shopping whatever you're doing if during
that time the entire time you're using
the tools that we have available podcast
self-published novels IG TV short
stories and what bad whatever it is if
you were just working the IP and
building audience what happens is when
you finally get into the room with
somebody whether it's a production
company for that you're pitching it to
for you if you want adoption or to a
private equity investor you can now have
the data and the analytics of market pre
awareness 2.2 because when you walk in
the room with zero brand recognition and
zero fans you're having a different
conversation than somebody that can
point say I have three hundred thousand
people who who love my IP that engage
with me and cross for four or five
different channels such as the different
conversation because you've you've
switched the risk analysis and that's
one thing we talked about one of the
previous videos is is studios they don't
necessarily love great content they love
low risk and the way to the way to skew
the risk is to build audience is just to
have audience and if when you have
audience all of a sudden people feel
like you're safer and so being able to
walk into a finance meeting and point to
audience gives you such a leg up because
now you shift that risk analysis into
your into your favor if you watch shark
tank the
saying that that that the Sharks asked
people is how many units have you sold
they don't ask how much money you're
looking for what's about how much equity
you trying to give up they ask those
questions at the end the very first
question they say is how many of you
sold your one that you'll mean invest in
your toothbrush how many toothbrushes
have you sold why do they ask that
they're asking that to gauge is this
risky or is it not and so somebody says
I've sold 400,000 toothbrushes in the
past year independently is less risky
than the person that sold zero
toothbrushes and in in the entertainment
space it's the same exact thing you you
want to be able to point to the data and
the analytics to be able to prove
audience so I think there's when we're
talking about investment I lean into
warren buffett warren buffett you don't
think of them as somebody like from the
film world or entertainment world but
you have to understand warren buffett's
a businessman who understands
investments and a lot of the people that
you go for investments you target for
investment aren't entertainment people
they're you're rich orthodontist that's
in your neighborhood that just has some
money that you want to be able to go and
pitch this thing - they're not
entertainment people it's the the it's
the the person that made a bunch of
money in natural gas and oil or tech
stock they're business people so you
have to understand what motivates a
business person to be able to to want to
invest into into an opportunity and
there's there I think there's two major
components that you need to have
according to Warren Buffett you need
market pre awareness and you need
scalability and so market free awareness
is being able to show that there are
people that want your product is there
pre awareness in the marketplace we've
seen this in Hollywood for the past 40
years when they say is it based off a
book you know if you if your if your
screenplay is based off of a successful
book it will it will get option faster
than one that's not and and and
anybody's out there shopping will attest
to that that's it that's why the option
the the book optioning market comic-book
option markets super competitive because
people want to be able to get that
market pre awareness and leverage that
into a deal so you need that market pre
awareness but you also need scalability
so what's the market opportunity in the
long term how big is this not big and
how long is this investment so is it a
is it a two year window of revenue is it
a one-year window of revenue is it a
ten-year window of revenue or a 20 year
window of revenue so how big can we make
this thing it's just a one-off or how
big can we go and so a lot of times we
think about transmedia in the
scalability aspect of it how big can we
make it it can be toys and video games
and and TV and film and all these big
things right that's great because that
shows market opportunity but we also
need to use transmedia
on a smaller scale to be able to shift
the pre awareness game and so if you can
show pre awareness and scalability and
just have a good idea all of a sudden
you have armed yourself with everything
that you need to be able to go into to
an investment meeting and point to to to
you know the the assets that you have as
far as your pitch and so so
understanding how your pre awareness
shifts the risk and how your scalability
increases market opportunity is a really
valuable thing to have and unless you
use a multi-platform trans mediated
model you're not going to get either one
of those things so all that to say we
have to we have to think in a broader
term of what the IP is I think this is
the thing that that Warren Buffett
really Warren Buffett really in a
commoditized market so I talk a lot
about the entertainment industry now
being commoditized and so what I mean by
commoditized is there's a lot of people
making similar products right and if
competition in the marketplace is so
crazy we have zillion things on Netflix
is zillion things on Hulu Amazon
anything that comes out in the theater
network TV TV cable TV premium TV
you know we have like every it's
entertainment is commoditized because
there's so many options that everything
is a little less special and so Warren
Buffett tells business people don't make
investments into products that are
currently in commoditized markets unless
they can shift pre awareness they have
good scalability and they have brand
value if you have brand value all of a
sudden you you can survive in a
commoditized market Warren Buffett also
says that one of the things that help
you helps you compete in a in a
commoditized market is volume and
diversification so this is business
principles so Warren Buffett says if
there's if the if the market is
oversaturated and there's there's
there's like a hundred times more stuff
out there then you actually need to
produce more things into the marketplace
right to be able just just to be not
washed away right because we've gone
from a pond to an ocean and if you wanna
make a splash in the ocean you need to
have more of a presence in that ocean so
volume is a strategy within a
commoditized market just general
business principle how does that now
equate to entertainment which is now
commoditized that means now we have to
have we have to have more things more
stories into the marketplace or houston
it's is it how can I make more movies
like it takes a long time to make a
movies now I'm trying to make it look
one movie let alone ten movies exactly
you can't make 10 movies simultaneously
and put them all out at the same time
it's too hard too expensive too
difficult takes is it's just that's
impossible
so now we have to then use the second
component which is diversification so
now we have our movie that can be one
touch point of the brand maybe the
tentpole of the brand but now we're
pushing volume through diversification
so now we're thinking about what are my
digital assets what what are what's my
my social assets what are my immersive
assets arv are you know how can I have
publishing involved you know what could
like how can I now push volume out on
the front end and the back end to end
by that across mediums and platforms
that now allow me to compete in the
commoditize market
why are we talking about this because
the businessman that you're pitching to
understands this stuff the biggest one
of the biggest failings of independent
writers and producers and filmmakers is
when they go to pitch they think they're
pitching to themselves that the person
on the other side of the table thinks
like them that if your filmmaker that
leans into if your DP and you may love
your color palettes and your your
cinematography and you may have
storyboards and you can talk about
lenses and all these things this is what
you love this is part of your art and
you're going to create the most the your
most beautiful film ever that's great
the odds are the orthodontist or the
investment banker or the the rich lady
and the next seed doesn't understand
that stuff or even if she does she may
not be excited about it what they
understand is business and what they
understand is investment and they
understand rate of return and return on
investment they understand risk they
understand volume they understand
diversification they understand branded
ecosystems and all this sounds like a
foreign language I can imagine all the
people watching the video now and I'm
turning into the Charlie Brown teacher
wah wah wah wah because they say I don't
want to think about that stuff because
I'm a writer I'm a filmmaker
I just want to worry about making my
movie I just wish that person would have
been born 30 years ago like if they were
born not just born 30 years ago like
active in the industry 30 years ago if
they were active in the industry 30
years ago it's a different ballgame now
it's so competitive the world's so
different you have to think about these
other things and so understanding it's
it's empathy it's empathy it's it's
empathetic pitching so if you understand
what concerns that the other person has
then you will be better at pitching your
project you'll be better at position
your your your art and your project for
an investment so what do investors care
about what do investors get excited
about what do they look for and then how
do I design my project and my my
proposition in such a way that
alleviates those concerns or those they
hit the touch points that excite them
and so the more you do that the more
successful you'll be at in getting these
investments so if you know if you know
that that investors are concerned about
volume diversification propre awareness
this shifts risk scalability that
increases market opportunity why would
you ever pitch anything that doesn't
have any of that stuff there and so but
the only way you're going to be able to
get that in an entertainment perspective
is using a multi-platform transmedia
super story approach because again you
can't make a hundred movies now you have
to have a plan to be able to use all
these different assets one really
interesting story to tell you that I
think is a really inspirational and
really cool and that makes this whole
thing real is there was a student that
that approached me with a short film
idea they were shooting a reshoot a
thesis film to graduate film school and
they needed to raise $12,000 to to shoot
their short film and he said Houston
when you look at my business plan and I
looked at his business plan and his
business plan was give me $12,000 and
I'll make my short film I'm gonna put it
into festivals and as I win the
festival's I'll give you the prize money
until you're $12,000 is paid back that
was the plan when I read that I I
applaud this guy for coming up with that
but I'm thinking again like the like a
businessman no way I invest in that
$12,000 into that into that business
plan why it's because one it's hard to
get into festivals and it's even harder
to win I mean that's the thing that any
filmmaker understands is very super
super competant
so me as an investor I'm gonna look at
that and say that's risky like it's very
very low a rate of return I'm probably
gonna lose this money and so I encourage
this student I said hey I don't think
this is gonna go you can try it I don't
think it'll work I think you would be
better off potentially just asking
people for like a go fund me donation he
didn't want to do that he wanted to
actually try to get the investment and
so he identified an investor in Florida
that he wanted to approach with this
opportunity and this guy owns seven car
Lots
and his mom was connected to this guy on
on Facebook and they were friends and so
he I just had it again this is not an
entertainment guy
it's a guy that sells cars and so so for
three days we sort of repackaged his
pitch so what we did was we went and we
did a transmedia plan for that and we
went from a product century eccentric
view of the of the of the opportunity
and made an IP centric view of the
opportunity so IP being the larger
intellectual property right and so we
quickly what this what this kid had in
spades was a really cool idea he had a
cool creative idea and so we for two
days we workshop the idea and we we
developed we developed a podcast we
developed a self-published novel we
developed a concept for a digital comic
book we developed a concept for a
musical EP he knew some people at the
Music School that were that was that he
contacted they said they would create
six songs that extended the story they
would do it will inspect for him and
they had a rev share that they were
going to do we we sketched out the
self-published novel we sketched out a
feature film and a TV series and we
figured and they all told different
stories within the same story world they
were all connected together in this
really interesting way and they all work
for one whole big puzzle and so then
became I want you to invest in not into
my short film I want you to invest into
the IP itself right so now your
financial you the investor our financial
partner into my in my intellectual
property so what we're going to do first
is we're going to take the $12,000 and
we're going to put it into the short
film because that's what I need to shoot
the short film for but listen we know
that short films probably won't make
money I'll put it in the festivals and
if I win then I'll give you some give
you the prize money
but the point of the short film no
longer is driving revenue primarily it's
building audience we're gonna put it
into festivals start to build an
audience with this cool idea we're gonna
release the podcast that I can produce
myself for free that's gonna build
audience it's going to get eyeballs
we're gonna release the music which is
gonna get a whole different demographic
of people and also build audience and
get and build excitement and if the
music makes any money you participate in
the profit of that I'm gonna write it
write my own novel self publish it
that's gonna be on Amazon that's gonna
build an audience but if that like
through the book sales if that starts
making money you participate the
investor participate in the profit of
that the digital comic books will be up
on the website his his brother was a
illustrator and said he would spec out
one issue for him if when that's a 99
cent download investor will participate
in the profit of that that's also gonna
build audience the plan is then to do
that for two years we're gonna work the
podcast work the novel work the music
there was there was a release window of
like when they ever think it was gonna
be released I'm we're gonna work that
for two years
wild the kid writes the feature film
script right as this being developed as
it's being written that all this stuff
is going to be there with after that two
years if if everything works out the the
the plan will be will have enough
audience and pre awareness to then start
approaching production companies to
option the script but we're not just
going to be some but an IP that no one's
ever heard of we can point to our brand
awareness and we can
point to our audience and we can point
to our community of fans and so now we
have at least have a puncher's chance to
be able to sell the feature if the
feature sells you the investor
participate in the profit of that and
then you know listen this is pie in the
sky long-term thinking if the film does
well and we sort of have this like cult
success on our hands its indie success
maybe then we can sell it as a TV series
and and if that goes you participate in
the profit of that and so now it's a
it's a ten-year plan rather than just a
short full plan but you can see
immediately how that just became a whole
other thing like that from an investment
perspective the investor looks at that
completely differently it seems it seems
like a bigger opportunity it seems it
seems reasonable and and this guy sells
car Lots so we went oh he has cars seven
car Lots he sells cars we went and put
the car locked in every story because
what does the car lock guy care about
most is selling cars cares about his car
Lots so we made it a location in the
story world and we made sure it was in
every story so we he works that up into
a pitch deck the whole plant is there
you know it works the he does the
business the business the business plan
runs the numbers for all the stuff and
then goes off to Florida a couple weeks
later gives me a call after he gets
there he was been there a couple days
gives me a call and says houston I got
my investment I said you got your twelve
thousand dollar investment that's
amazing he said no I didn't get a twelve
thousand dollar investment I got a two
hundred and thirty thousand dollar
investment I said really like how did
you get a two hundred thirty thousand
dollar investment he said well I just
sat down with this guy and I laid all
this stuff out and this guy looked at me
and said you know what this makes
business sense and he says I don't know
anything about entertainment but this
makes business sense and then the guy
said he said do you know how much money
I waste in marketing across my car Lots
every year and and he said I he said he
wastes about 40% of his marketing budget
just on Billboard's no one ever sees
commercials no one ever watches and he
said because this makes business sense
and because you have the car lot in here
can take 10% of my marketing budget
across all seven of my Lots and I'll
just invest it into the IP because if it
doesn't work I was gonna waste the money
anyway but if it does work all of a
sudden the business model seems
interesting enough to where this could
be a good long-term investment for me
and all of a sudden this could be huge
for me and my brand and the fact that
the car Lots in there may it will
probably do you know it'll market my car
lots better than then my regular crappy
used-car lot
commercials will is that people will
come to my car lot just because it's
like a movie location and it taps into
all of the thing and so all of a sudden
repositioning that that project from a
product centric point of view to an IP
perspective view IP perspective that one
had a plan of how do you build pre
awareness that shifts the risk but then
also how do you increase scalability on
the backend that increases your market
opportunity and how do you make it make
business sense for the person across the
table now if if if that didn't work and
he was going to an orthodontist who has
money in the next he will probably
have to change that take the car let out
do something else right and so so you
have to be you you probably not just
gonna have one pitch for for your IP you
you need to design it for the person to
whom you're pitching make it a tailored
suit rather than the suit they have to
fit in and so all of a sudden this this
from an independent perspective this
makes an independent private equity
venture a hundred times more interesting
and more valuable than just the person
that has the one script or the one movie
idea or the one short film or whatever
it is so again do you have to figure it
out a little bit more of course right
but but I think a problem is there's a
lot of people that want to achieve what
other people have without doing the same
amount of work that other people do and
so yeah like we just we live in a time
that independent creators have to do
more work than ever before to be able to
survive in a commoditized oversaturated
entertainment market but at the same
time we're blessed to live in a time
where we have so many tools that my
parents my grandparents my
great-grandparents never had right so
it's so it swings both ways you just
have to get out of that that same
mindset see the opportunities all of a
sudden went to be if you're able to
implement those opportunities your
investment pitch it's a completely
different conversation so for some of us
screenwriters out there are people who
love to write stories is that like a
market for people who can write
transmedia projects kind of on spec the
same way I'd write like a script for a
TV show that I love if I like identify
story world out there in the market that
might not be like utilized as much as I
think it could would I be able to write
a spec transmedia project for that and
get a meeting to pitch that to those
types of people does that happen in the
industry very often so developing
transmedia projects on spec absolutely
could happen and if you have a vision of
how a story can extend across multiple
platforms as a way to build more revenue
to engage audiences to build brand
equity to be able to build built you
know revive in a public domain story
world or maybe it's an original story
world and you can do it inspect whatever
it is you can absolutely do that on spec
now how you pitch it is gonna be
depending on depending on who you pitch
to and so if you're pitching that to a
movie producer or a movie studio then
then you probably don't want to go in
with all your trends media guns blazing
right at first you want to if they're in
the business of film you want to be able
to push that your film the film idea
within the plan the front and center and
you want to have that be the centerpiece
tentpole driving platform of the whole
project and then everything else are
ancillary opportunities to scale the
project bigger in the long term to be
able to front-load pre awareness before
the film comes out or etc etc etc if you
if
walk into a book publisher to pitch to a
book book publisher you're gonna have
the novel front and center if you walk
into a television network and have a TV
show front and center if you walk into a
private equity opportunity then you can
kind of position the the whole brand
front and center and how everything
interplays so it really just depends on
how you pitch it to whom you're talking
to but I think as far as specking things
out and and go ahead and understanding
and developing how the story interplays
across multiple platforms I'm very
bullish on I'm a big fan of doing that
because I think that then shows what the
opportunity is to the person to whom
you're pitching and so if you just walk
in just with the film pitch and then
after the film pitch you say oh yeah
well and we could do this and this and
this and she's kind of spinning off the
top of your head that doesn't have the
substance of you've been able to say and
here's the film but then here's the
strategy that I want to use to be able
to generate audience while the film is
in development pre-production production
and post-production I want to be able to
work this thing for two years across
these four platforms that are gonna get
the demographic that we need and here's
how I'm gonna do it here are the story
ideas that are work on that platform
natively designed for those platform
forms so you have to understand the type
of stories that work on Instagram as
opposed to the type of stories that work
on snapchat as opposed to the type of
stories that work as a short story on
Wattpad whatever it is here's the story
ideas that are natively designed for
those platforms then here after we
released the film I want to be able to
release these three things to be able to
extend the the experience of the people
that go to the theater and then two
years down the road if everything goes
well I want to be able to do this this
this this and here's how it all plays
together and then what they'll see is
there was a secret that we posed in the
in the Wattpad short story that was
released a year before the film ever
came out that we're now going to pull on
and be able to develop this other thing
that we're gonna then you know release
there you know three years down the road
etc etc etc and all of a sudden now you
you you should one show your strategic
expert
and it seems more substantial you know
when it comes to investment in pitching
investors they bet on the horse and they
bet on the jockey and the horse is the
product you gotta have a good script I
have a good product
right but they also bet on the jockey
the problem bet on the jockey especially
if you're an independent filmmaker or a
filmmaker who's early in their career
and you'll have the credits that other
jockeys have you have to be able to
display an expertise or a value that
makes makes that investor say this
person has something special and and if
if if this is your first film your
second film and you don't have the the
big IMDB page if you can show the
transmedia strategy of how to grow the
brand then all of a sudden in my
experience as long as it's good right
the mean that the creative is the
variable right means sometimes people
don't get investments not because it's a
bad model just because it's a bad story
or they haven't executed the story so
let's just presume that's a good idea a
good story the whole thing then you're
able to show your expertise your value
this person has something special that
that they have this thing planned out
and now this jockey may not be like the
other jockeys but it's something that I
can bet on and so so but how you
position that is is all dependent to
whom you're pitching when it goes back
to that empathetic pitching topic of to
whom you're pitching what do they care
about and how do I tailor the pitch to
them which means you may have seven
different or ten different or seventeen
different versions of your pitch so that
you can go around town and and pitch
different people but all of a sudden
it's really focused and targeted to them
but I think if the fundamental question
is do I go ahead and spec this thing out
I think the more you spec it out the
better the more you spec out the better
if you can actually execute some of the
some of the front end pre awareness
transmedia ideas and actually point to
your audience that's the better that
that's the best if you can't do that
then at least have the plan of this is
what I'm going to do is
we do this deal as soon as we get
solidified this is my strategy and the
more you have I think it's always the
better if you can have a script written
that's better than having a treatment
written I think if you if you can't have
the treatment written have something
have a good one sheet if you can't have
a one sheet have something if you just
walk in with an idea ideas or a
dime-a-dozen we've heard a thousand
times the old cliche right like people
don't invest into ideas anybody weakens
all sit in a room and come up with a
hundred thousand amazing ideas that
would be great transmedia projects great
movies great TV shows but that's not
what people invest into they invest into
ideas that have execution attached to it
will the person execute on the idea and
how can you show people that you can't
execute on the idea and the more
substance you have and the more strategy
you have the more vision you have the
more enthusiasm you have that all lends
itself to the horse is good and the
jockey is good
you've mentioned Wattpad several times
so that's a blogging platform yeah so so
what pad is a social media maybe it's
nice associate I'm not sure how that
it's it's what pad is a platform for
people write short stories and share
short stories one of the hottest places
that is being optioned for film right
now is Wattpad agents producers studios
networks there every single month
combing through Wattpad finding short
stories one that I have good ideas but
they're seeing where the audiences go
it's a cool thing about digital
platforms is you can see all the
analytics you can see how many likes
they have how many followers they have
all that stuff and so they see though
this is a cool story and this is the
audiences are gravitating to this all of
a sudden they use the data and they
analytics the option that story to then
develop into a feature and so so right
now that I think the two hottest
platforms to end mediums to understand
to be able to get optioned isn't the
spec script it's Wattpad and podcasts
there were there were eight podcast
optioned for TV last fall ate that but
one of my favorite I thought was amazing
was dirty John dirty John was a
tremendous podcast based off of LA Times
article developed into a podcast based
on the success of the podcast got his a
Connie Britton was in a TV show it was a
ad I think picked it up right and so ABC
picked up several podcasts all the
networks are our mining podcast and
mining Wattpad for for material because
it shows it shows pre awareness in the
marketplace right and for independent
producers it's very competitive to jump
to jump around town trying to option the
books like novels trying to option
novels before other people super
competitive and super expensive The
Hunger Games the novels of the Hunger
Games were actually option three months
before they ever hit the market and so
the option game with novels is crazy and
most of us like mere mortals don't have
thirty thousand dollars or fifty
thousand dollars laying around but I can
slap down on an option on a book and so
and so now independent producers are
looking at other places where stories
come from and that's where one the
public domain is is is important but now
Wattpad and podcasts are really ripe for
for people to swoop in and option some
things in a less competitive market now
the problem with that is now the
network's are starting to like get hip
on Wattpad and podcast and so now
there's more competition in those
markets but there's always going to be
you know whether it's Instagram
whether it's snapchat whatever it is
these platforms have they can be used to
cede IP so if I know that as an
independent creator if I know that their
that their networks and studios and
agents and producers trolling trolling
in a good way
Wattpad and podcast for content then all
of a sudden I'm gonna say why don't I
have a short story on Wattpad and a
podcast on the only on the iTunes Store
and have my feature film ready to go
because now what I've done is I've
increased my odds of getting a
exposure and being discovered and I can
point to the pre awareness of the
audience that I a grenade on those
platforms and so I can point to the
number of people that are read by that
I've read my short story point to them
to be number of people that subscribe to
my to my podcast and if that's enough to
get me the meeting I can say and the
feature film script is already ready and
so it's just maximizing the opportunity
I honestly I don't understand why
everybody doesn't do that the reason
people don't do that is they don't want
to take the time to learn how to do the
podcast they don't want to take the time
to like learn how to do the short story
and Wattpad and it seems you know I
don't like social media everybody just
argues about Donald Trump and all that
like that's true don't use it to argue
politics use it to seed and leverage
your IP to be able to get to the point
that working you can do the things that
you want to do and these are
opportunities that have never been
available in human history and people
are using them for dumb stuff like let's
use them as a tool for independent
creators in this amazing way to a bit of
flip it to where now you can really live
your dream of being on set shooting your
movie you know optioning your script
whatever it is in order to get there
there are opportunities that are just
sitting on the table ready to go how
does one know if something is in the
public domain
there there web sites that that collect
all this stuff and that that that you
know if you google like public domain
science fiction and public domain
fantasy there are websites that will
catalog all the the things that have
already moved into the public domain and
then so what I would suggest is is go
there first and then begin developing
out of there first eventually you just
probably want to double check with an
attorney just to make sure but it's 70
years after the death of the author
typically things move into the into the
public domain but but double check with
IRB's Ernie before you you know produce
something but there but to get but but
there are certain services but there are
websites that catalog all that
information that a great resources to
tap into I know you said that numerous
people have reached out to you since our
interview about
and a half ago and I'd love to hear all
of the emails but one in particular that
you were just talking about reading
beforehand was about sort of the moral
issue of transmedia and I'm probably not
saying it correctly but Keane what the
email was about sure this is the real
common question that I that I get from
people is is transmedia
immoral and and it kind of you know
first time someone asked me that I
thought it was it I didn't understand
what they were saying and like digging
in with with with these people to have
those questions it's it sort of rooted
in is this just capitalistic
exploitation of the audience is this
manipulation of the audience or you
taking advantage of people in a bad way
and you know is this just the is this
just a big cash grab that you don't
really care about the people you just
care about taking their money and
there's all these issues that that
people have with it
and my you know my typical answer is
that like anything transmedia can be
used in an immoral way of course like it
depends on who the crater is and it
depends on what their intentions are and
what they're trying to do are there
people out there trying to just use it
as a cash grab are they like just you
know capitalistic jerks that are just
trying to take advantage of
opportunities and and of course just
just like regular film producers they're
they're doing the same thing or
television producers or like morality
doesn't have anything to do with
platforms it's all about the intention
of the creator and the intention of the
business people that are trying to sort
of propagate this idea and this model
and whatever they're trying to do in the
venture so so is transmedia
immoral per se of course not you know I
mean if my my kitchen knife is an
immoral per se if I use my kitchen ice
to stab you then all of a sudden I've
committed an immoral thing with an with
a you know a morally neutral object
right so a solid depends on on the
intention so I I'm when it comes to like
the capitalism aspect
of it like I'm very passionate that we
were speaking about this before I'm very
passionate that that artists don't have
to be starving artists that artists
don't have to choose between making
money and and and doing their art and
that's usually people feel like it's a
binary choice people feel like I can
either sell out and and make money or I
can pursue my art which is somehow more
pure right and and really I think in
traditional entertainment that has been
the choice that people make is I can
either make studio movies or superhero
crap or I can do make the movies that I
love and and so you're either forced
into these one of these two options I
think in a 1i I'm not opposed to making
money I mean I'm very I'm very much a
capitalist I'm very much like I love the
fact that we live in America that allows
us to create an opportunity to be able
to maximize our brand to maximize the
opportunities in a way that allows me to
feed my family and and have this be my
career I think that's awesome I what I
want for every screenwriter out there
every filmmaker out there every producer
every director is is I want them to be
able to do their dream has their career
I don't want them to work at Burger King
and make movies on the weekend like no
offense against Burger King I don't want
them to have to like work at Starbucks
or Hobby Lobby as they try to like have
filmmaking be their side hustle like if
they're doing that that's awesome that's
what you have to do but eventually what
my wish is for them is is they get to a
level where they can just do filmmaking
full-time and in order to get there you
either need to be independently wealthy
or you need to be able to understand how
to generate revenue this is the
entertainment is is is creating product
that people will purchase by
spend their money on and if you don't
make stuff that people want to spend
money on then you're not going to be in
business very long no one's going to
invest into your stuff or no one's going
to come see it there's there's no
revenue flowing therefore you're you
can't make this your business it's a
very practical question I don't think
that's immoral to say I want to be a
career creator I want to be I want
filmmaking to be my career in order to
do that you have to figure out how to
make money now here's the cool thing
about transmedia this is why I think
transmedia
is the opposite of immoral really if you
think about it in that in the terms of
capitalism if if if let's say a
filmmaker wants to make a very non
commercial art house film that that you
you know that this very specific niche
II that that breaks all the conventions
it's very like terrence malick right
it's like terrence malick without
Terrence Malick's brand and so that's
probably not gonna get a wide
distribution it's probably not gonna get
picked up but this is this is the thing
that's in their heart that they want to
make so if that's all you have if that's
all you have then you're gonna have to
make the choice do I make this movie and
and have to do it on a small budget low
budget no budget and do it on the
weekends because nobody's going to
invest in it or it's not going to get
options not gonna be picked up
I can either I could either make that
movie or I can change it to two then add
the 3x structure and they can read a
Blake Snyder book and they can add the
save the cat stuff in it and make it
commercial and then all of a sudden now
I can sell it I can get the investment
except I get distribution for it etc etc
so both options I think are bad options
one option has you has you being a
starving artist which I think sucks
the other option has you selling your
soul in order and not doing the thing
that's in your heart just in order to be
able to you know have this be your full
I'm gig that's the binary option now in
a transmedia model that option that
binary choice isn't the choice anymore
now you can say you know what I'm gonna
do my weird terrence malick art house
film I'm going to do it as is now if you
have that as part of the bra of a
broader IP now all you have to say is if
this thing isn't going to make money
which it probably won't what are the
other things that I can do to surround
this film with that will generate my
revenue so if I can point to now a novel
or you know a digital thing or you know
a comic book series or a mobile game or
whatever it is that you can surround
this thing with and these other things
can generate revenue
now this weird art house thing could
almost be like a lost leader that fuels
the the the revenue and the interest of
these other things and so it doesn't
matter but the way the studio's work is
is they work with a resource allocation
model to where if they release 14 movies
in a year they know that all fourteen
movies aren't going to be solvent then
all not going to make money they they
hope and pray out of the 14 movies they
released a year that there's four
tentpoles
that that that overperformed to make up
for the deficits of the movies that
financially failed and they know that
moving into the year like every studio
knows that everything there they're
gonna do isn't gonna be a hit they they
know that most of the stuff is gonna
make is gonna lose money there's gonna
be a few things that make money those
things uphold the tint that's why they
call them tip poles so it's called a
resource allocation model if you take
that same thinking and apply that to a
transmedia project and if you say I know
my art house movie is not gonna make
money that's totally fine you still do
that because that's what's in your heart
but now you just need something else to
over perform and make enough money that
it that it that it compensates for the
deficit created by the film because the
film
cost money to make which means it's
gonna technically that that one element
is gonna lose money but as long as you
make that up somewhere else now it's a
net net gain and so and so usually when
I talk to to to indie filmmakers that
are very precious about their one thing
and they don't want to change it because
they don't want to make the binary
choice they're less precious about
things and other platforms right like
they're fine with having a New York
Times bestselling novel and doing a very
commercialized novel they just don't
want to change their movie right they're
fine with having a very successful
mobile game like classic ant clans but
they just don't want to change their
movie and so and so all of a sudden for
the people that don't want to make the
binary choice the transmedia model is
the perfect thing for them because now
they can they can figure out how to
maintain the artistic integrity of the
one thing that they love while figuring
out how to drive revenue from other
places and with that you can still be
able to better position that for
investment I had a wonderful maker that
was telling me he said he said I make
movies for me I don't care if anyone
likes them and I don't care if they make
money I make him I make it for me
and and I said I said that's great I
said you know what do you want to do I
said I want to be a career from it
filmmaker my question is how are you
going to finance it you can you imagine
going to an investor interview and
saying I want you to give me a million
dollars to make my movie but I don't
care if anyone likes it and I don't care
it makes money it's not gonna happen
it's not gonna happen
and so but if you walk into the investor
and say listen my movie is gonna be
weird it's gonna be art house that's
gonna be niche I don't care if this
makes money but that's okay because I
make it money here here here here here
and it's all gonna work together right
but my movie the artistic integrity of
my movie is gonna be maintained that
investor affair all if all the numbers
line up in the bottom line lines up now
you at least have a puncher's chance for
before you had zero chance so so all of
a sudden like you don't have to make
that choice which i think changes that
calculation a little bit about whether
this is a good thing or a bad thing
is this just commercialism gone awry or
is it actually a tool for independent
artists to be able to do the things that
they
love for the rest of their lives and and
that's that I think shifting that
thinking is is is a big shift now the
other thing about this is that I think
is really important is is something that
I call soapbox the so a soapbox is
basically a the theme the message of
your of your film like where how do you
how does your film how does your script
tap into like the passion that's in your
heart what are you trying to say what
what is your commentary on the world how
do you make your your project feel not
just cool but important because it's
tapped in to something I think the
greatest art from throughout history
comes from the passion and perspective
and the heart of the creator I think you
know things like something like get out
what they came from like the heart of
the crater and it had an importance
attached to it not just a cool factor it
wasn't just a cool high concept it was
it felt like an important film because
it was and I think when you when you
when you read Hemingway or you listen to
an Aretha Franklin song there there's
something about the passion and the
authenticity about what these creators
want to say with her art that makes this
art sustainable and makes the art
resonate better with the audience I
think Tarantino every every every film
that that he that that he makes is is
just dripping with his passion and you
can see it and it comes across in a very
soulish intangible way but the audience
receives it differently so if in today's
world it's important to do things and to
create things not just because they have
a you have a cool high concept idea it's
because you're actually passionate about
an issue passionate about something a
perspective something of importance that
gives your story a moral depth to it
that that is interesting now that could
be in something like you know something
like get out or something like Romo or
on the other end I think you know I
think George Lucas was saying something
very important and specific when he
created Star Wars he was supposed to
direct Apocalypse Now you before Francis
Ford Coppola
because he was so passionate about the
Vietnam War the movie got delayed so we
wouldn't did Star Wars instead which I
think ultimately was better for
Apocalypse Now but the but he took all
all the passion he had for imperialism
and colonialism and overreaching
government and that same passion that
made him a hippie back in the 60s as a
college student he poured that into like
a larger IP personally I don't think
that black pen black panther technically
is one of the best pictures as far as
like the Oscar conversation I don't
think that the technical aspect of black
panther is best picture worthy but black
panther had the technical had you know I
think solid superhero technicality they
got great costumes whole thing but black
panther was routed and tapped into an
importance that that elevates the film
above just being a normal superhero
movie it's important to people it's
important to culture and it connects to
people's hearts because of what it
stands for and so if if if if creators
understand what they want to say with
their art not just how to make money but
what they want to say what are you
trying to say as a person as a human
being what are you trying to convey like
they would like the world's on fire in
the thousand different ways and
filmmakers have an opportunity and to to
have a platform to actually say
something about the world and in today's
environment that's actually wanted and
desired by the audience is it's not an
agenda and the millennial generation
they're not like like my generation with
my parents generation where we just
wanted popcorn stuff they they want
something real and authentic and
important and so I say all this to say
as a filmmaker if you have something
important to say and if you put it in
your movie and you release your movie
some people will hear your message and
there'll be the people to watch a movie
but in today's oversaturated come
Tai's highly competitive entertainment
landscape not everybody watches movies
right what about the the people that
don't go to the movies and all they do
is listen to music or play video games
or what about the people that don't
watch TV or movies at all just they play
board games all the time there's so much
stuff that people what about the kids
that all they do is they have their nose
in the book and they just read all the
time do they not need to hear your
message as well if they're so important
to you if your message is act actually
important if you have commentary on on
immigration issues or racial issues or
political issues or not just any
political hot-button issues but if
you're passionate about anything then
then doesn't the person that's in the in
the basement playing board games don't
they need to hear that as well
the kid that just sits on their phone
and plays mobile games don't they need
to hear what you have to say as well
of course they do if your message is
actually important of course they do all
of a sudden in order to reach all those
people you have to diversify the way
that like you have to diversify your IP
because once you start looking at
transmedia less as a cash grab and more
as an opportunity to deploy your message
and your passion and your heart to
everybody doing everything around the
world all of a sudden makes a lot more
sense right now your IP is becoming all
things to all people right and being
able to operate and connect that message
with everybody's heart which then leads
them back into a community of people
community of other fans that all share
that that that same you know that same
message and that's what makes the that's
what makes IP important right so so
talking about this question the
immorality I think again goes back to
the motivations but if your motivation
is I want to I want to change the world
in a positive way
I want to impact the world with this
very important thing that's coming out
of my soul then transmedia is the
perfect thing for you because now you're
getting into everybody that needs it and
not everybody does not everybody does it
no one does everything
but everybody does something if that
makes sense so there nobody like please
videogames watches movies listen to
music like nobody does everything
because there's so much stuff right but
everybody does something and in order to
reach everybody in this world now we
have to diversify the way we deploy the
message or deploy the passion and that's
where transmedia becomes beneficial
let's suppose we're gonna do a workshop
right here today building a story world
sure how would we begin it so we're
talking about story world's we need to
separate stories from story worlds so
story worlds are places and stories are
things that happen in those places and
so a lot of what I found a lot of people
they they don't understand what a story
world is I you know some people say well
my my story world is my you know
characters coming of age sexuality or
whatever that's not a story world that's
some like a character arc a story world
literally is a geographical place it's
it's it's it you know we know we
understand the story of Lord of the
Rings and Frodo and the ring and the
journey destroy the ring but the the
story world is middle-earth
so neo story is in the matrix is about
his adventure with with Morpheus and
taking down the matrix and against the
machines the agent Smith and all that
stuff but the story world the matrix is
a futuristic earth that's been taken
over by machines and they use people as
batteries in the VR environment so story
worlds are places and that's what you
have to understand but it's not just any
place it's any place that is interesting
has to be interesting by itself and so
most people when they when they develop
content they develop scripts or their TV
for our features or books the most
interesting things they have are their
characters and their plots and then they
relegate story world to setting as your
setting is just simply where my story
takes place but just because you have a
setting doesn't necessarily mean you
have a story world a story world is a
setting that has independent interest so
it's interest that's independent of any
character independent of any story so my
rule of thumb
is can you take your main character your
protagonist or hero
can you take them out of the story world
and have your story world still be
interesting right can you take the story
out of the story world and still have it
be interesting so I can right now take a
Luke Skywalker out of Star Wars and the
Star Wars Galaxies still interesting I
can take Frodo
out of middle-earth middle-earth
middle-earth is still interesting I can
take baymax out of big hero 6 and San
fransokyo still interesting right but
can you take rocky out of rocky it's a
different calculation right because you
think well they're doing that with creed
what creed still has rocky but I mean
it's it's if we take rocky at Iraqi then
we have Philadelphia which is the
setting but there's nothing
independently interesting about
Philadelphia no offense to Philadelphia
right so but but the interest of rocky
comes through rocky and Creed and the
characters but the place itself isn't
interesting you look at something like
Gotham with Batman you can take Batman
out of Gotham and you can have a whole
TV show about it right because the place
in and of itself is super interesting
and when you have an interesting setting
that creates your story world you now
you now have stored potential and so you
will never any creator any any writer
any director any filmmaker they will
never truly understand the revenue
potential of their brand or their IP
unless they actually understand their
story world story worlds create story
potential story potential creates
revenue potential and and so and then
revenue potential makes buyers happy
they make you know the investors happy
they keep us happy the the creators
happy let me get ready happy and so but
if you don't understand your story world
you won't understand that story
potential so so in story worlds are a
really important tool to be able to
maximize the storm potential in your IP
so you just have to understand first off
what a story world is like what it is at
all then how do we how do we create it
so so a couple a couple easy ways that
that some easy tips that people can
start thinking about as they create
story world
is they need to be thinking first about
their theme about what they want to say
and about what their perspective is it
goes back to that passion like what
what's the what what what's the
commentary that they're trying to put
into any individual story and then once
you understand that then the starting
point for a great story world is a place
that needs your soapbox or your theme so
for example if you if you if your theme
was all about income inequality about
how the evils of income inequality there
and you want to show people that and and
and tell people that equality of income
is actually like the ideal for society
let's see that's what you wouldn't say
the starting place or the starting point
for your story world is a place that
needs that message which means that's a
place where income inequality is gonna
be a tremendous problem that's your
starting point
it isn't just like oh I'll just set it
in Philadelphia or I'll set it in a
fantasy world with Wizards that's not
the starting point the starting point is
what am I trying to say with my movie
what am I trying to say with my book
where I want to try to say with my video
game and what's a world that needs to
hear that message and so if you if under
the income inequality example maybe your
story world is a sci-fi story world like
at Lycia where the rich folks live in
the sky and the poor folks live you know
on the ground or maybe it's a real world
store world like India where
billionaires and slum Dogz live like two
blocks apart
right so it can it can be or anywhere on
that spectrum right Angeles or Los
Angeles exactly and so but that's the
starting point is what's the world that
needs my what's a world that needs my
soapbox or needs my theme one of my
favorite story worlds just in the past
couple years is a show called godless
that was on Steven Soderbergh produced
it for now Netflix great high-concept
which was which was a town with us Old
West town where all the men and the town
died in a mining accident and so the
only people that are left in the town
are the women and the women sort of run
the you know run run the town protect
the town do everything in the town and
so so you if you listen to the creator's
talk the thing that they wanted to say
with the show it's a great show I think
they wanted to say is that women can be
every bit as strong as men women can do
just as cool awesome interesting cool
things as men that's what they wanted to
show they want to give a vehicle for
this message and so a world that need
that that needs to hear that could be a
medieval world could be a sci-fi world
but they children chose the Old West so
the Old West you know is all about like
the man's man on the horse and the women
and the dress that weighs the raise that
the kids at home and it was very
patriarchal in the way society was set
up and everybody looked through the men
to do the to do the cool awesome things
and no one looked at the women to do
those things and so the starting place
for that story world is a world that
needs that message which is the Old West
right and so and so that basically once
you understand your theme that kind of
puts guardrails on your the ideation
process of your story world to where now
you just know you need a world that need
your theme which will necessarily
eliminate certain ideas right so so you
don't if it's in a income inequality you
don't want to have your story world be a
place where income and quality isn't a
problem it'll eliminate those others
story world options and then limit you
to the ones that do but ultimately if
you do that the benefit of this is that
it takes your soap box and your theme
and it bakes it into the cake of the
story world itself so that every story
that you ever explore within that story
world will naturally intrinsically
communicate your message it will be in
the DNA but woven into the DNA of the
story will itself we never no matter
where we go in Jurassic Park
they never to have to tell us that it's
a bad idea to have made dinosaurs we
just know it and we know it because the
the the the soap box of of Jurassic Park
which i think is don't play God because
when we try to play God we screw it up
that is built into the idea
self it's built into the storyboard
itself and it's always there right which
is which is which is really interesting
and so so the starting point but with
with with story world it's what do you
want to say what's your perspective
what's your commentary and then how do
we create a world that needs that then
what you need to do is you need to layer
in I think a high concept which is which
is just a commercially interesting idea
something that is immediately
interesting and that can grab people's
attention and I think a lot of people
focus on high concept when it comes to
story and not and not all people don't
focus on how to create a high concept
for the world itself because the world
itself needs to be interesting and
commercial and it needs to grab people's
attention just as much as the characters
and the story so so a town that a town
where all the men died and completely
run by women it's a great high concept
right so so the interest isn't on a
specific character or a specific
storyline the interest is on the town
itself in what lost the the high concept
as a as an island that travels through
time and all this weird stuff happens we
can take any of those individual
characters out of that island that
island is still interesting because I
Island has a high concept the Skull
Island with the king in the King Kong
franchise there's something about Skull
Island
that creates giant animals so I can take
King Kong out of Scotland and they're
still interesting things there there's
the high concept is attached to the
world and so and so figuring out irony
of what's what's something that
surprises you about this world something
that is is interesting so I think
Zootopia is a great example and made it
sense to where this is a world where
where animals live as civilized humans
right and there's a that's irony and
that and the that's already attached to
the world itself then they were able to
take an ironic world and create an
ironic story or a high concept story
inside the high concept world where now
they had a little tiny bunny that one to
be a police officer and all
other police officers were like the
giant rhinos and everything so they had
a high concept character high cost plot
but the world itself was independently
high-concept right and that's what makes
the world interesting and that's what
creates the story potential over time so
so you have to think about so a lot of
us a lot of filmmakers will naturally
understand a logline
what's a log line for your story and
that's just a really one sentence way to
be able to encapsulate your plot and in
a way that's interesting it makes people
want to read your script I'm very
bullish on creating a log line for your
story world in addition to your
individual stories and so a log line a
story world log line goes something like
this a story world is a place where
ironic things happen that's a template I
always use for a story world and if you
can if you could just use that template
and say the story world is a place where
ironic things happen then you will
always have something interesting so for
example
Neverland is the story of rope Neverland
is a faraway Fantasyland where people
don't age and live as kids forever right
so the story world is a place
what kind of is what kind of places is
this city is it a country is it a galaxy
no it's a far we finish the land and
where's the irony what's the surprising
part of it what's the interesting part
of it it's a place where you don't age
and remain as a kid forever right so if
you go if you go through your story
world and you say can I make a story
about logline out of it that's
independently interesting and by adding
in irony and a high concept to the world
itself now you have some commercial 'ti
and some interest and something that is
that that by itself can grab people's
attention
what about Gilead in The Handmaid's Tale
or sauropod I don't know if you watched
sure sharp objects yeah what would about
that story world can you do so so
obviously with with that with with a
hand hammies tail I think the irony is
the high concept of that of that world
one that's it that's when we're talking
about soapbox and put your message and
how to create a story world that needs
that message when it talks about the
reproductive what rights of women I
think that's very clearly the commentary
of the
patriarchy controlling the reproductive
rights rights of women that's a world
that needs to hear that message
obviously and then then they layer in
the high concept which is you know not
not every woman can give birth and
there's some women that can give birth
that are not controlled and forced to
give birth but it's like these four
surrogates that's the big commercial
idea but it's the big commercial idea
rooted in an important message right
which is which is kind of interesting
how this flow together which gets you to
the point of where your story world is
now not just cool the coolness comes
through the high concept but it's also
important and the importance comes
through the soap box they work together
for the whole thing so I think The
Handmaid's Tale is a tremendous story
world tremendously interesting story
world outside of any individual
character outside of any individual
story someone can tell me the concept of
the story world itself and I'm in that's
interesting that's cool and now I want
to go check it out I can see that where
the story potential is etc etc I think
with with windgap and sharp objects I
think windgap is a small win a small
Midwest town where everybody has a
secret nothing is as it seems I mean
just the way they built that world was
really interesting even with like the
teenagers that rollerskate around town
that one little addition they're not
writing back to the roller skating which
added this really interesting element to
it right and so just the way they
crafted that world it wasn't just like
any other normal small town it was a
small town with a dark underbelly that
was very difficult for anybody to to tap
into it had this like weird veneer but
it was it was just a really interesting
world I think with with stranger things
right Hawkins is a small Indiana town
that is a portal to an other mere dark
mirror dimension right one sentence you
understand the high concept the
commercial 'ti of that world right I can
take Mike and the gang in the dimming
organ and everybody out of out of
stranger things and Hawkins is still
interesting because the high concept is
attached to the world itself the problem
is a lot of people design films and TV
and novels and things like that with the
high con
that attached to the character which
means if you pull the character out now
the place is no longer interesting which
means you've tied your IP to that
specific character which means you're
going to limit your story potential in
your story options across platform
because the high concepts with him The
Fresh Prince of bel-air
for example Fresh Prince of bel-air
right the height the high concept there
is the fish-out-of-water concept of you
know a west philly street hustler
who's removed from West Philly and now
lives in bel-air right that's the high
concept but if I take will out of The
Fresh Prince bel-air is no longer
interesting it's interesting because
he's there because the high concept
lives with him right same thing with
Beverly Hills Cop right it means the
same thing and Beverly Hillbillies the
whole thing right someone's take a
shared story world the people that
aren't supposed to be there that are
there right but if you if you take out
those characters now we can't follow one
of my favorite story roles is the left
overs
it's a HBO show three seasons tremendous
story world where two percent of the
world's population disappears instantly
and nobody knows where they went and the
hot so you can follow with with that
with that high concept you can follow
any character in that world
and the world is still interesting
because this is this is a world where
people can just disappear and you don't
know why right so we buy in and we're
interested because of the world that's
where the interest comes and then if you
can tell me I if you can tell me a
commercial story inside a commercial
world all of a sudden now you're hitting
on all levels right because ultimately
you have to have a great story inside a
high concept world else your product
isn't good but one of the if you
remember the movie Jupiter ascending
with Channing Tatum milah Kunis was the
the Wachowskis that you know after their
masterpiece of The Matrix they went and
created Jupiter ascending which I
thought it was a tremendous story world
but a really really bad story and so
when you have a great world and a bad
story everything falls apart because
your product just simply isn't good and
the same with Tomorrowland with George
Clooney Tomorrowland is awesome but the
movie
bad so so that sort of killed the whole
thing but if you can tell a great story
inside a great world this is when you
have IP potential forever because your
product is great and the story world is
independently interesting which is gonna
create more more opportunities for you
moving forward what about the original
Blade Runner I think the whole world of
Blade Runner is really interesting I
think the world itself I think is high
concept so you know with the replicants
and and you know and and you know our
people sort of these robots aren't they
robots or like you know like that whole
the world is interesting and especially
even this in the in the Scimitar fee the
the the color this is the new film blood
rather 2049 like you just see it like
the way they colorize it and and and
insert this like steampunk dystopian
future the world I think like without
what you take Karason for it out still
cool like it's just still really
interesting but dune is another great
one like you take you like like that's a
great story world and so so so for fans
like you can take the Starks the Starks
at a game of thrones i think gamers are
still interesting right like the the
high concept is with with the place now
i think you can even take you can take
wall-e out of wall-e and the world is
still interesting right and so so this
is just an interesting tactic to judge
does the world have viability in and of
itself right so you want to have a
soapbox to sort of sort of spurs the
initial creation then you want to layer
in the high concept which builds the
interest of mortal engines which Peter
the new Peter Jackson movie that's
coming out based on the books I think
it's a really interesting high concept
where where this is a dystopian future
where cities roll around on wheels like
tank wheels so London rolls around and
it like cities move and I saw the teaser
I've never read the books I saw the
teaser and I said huh that's weird I
don't know why cities roll around on
wheels in this weird dystopian future
but they do and now I'm interested
because I buy into the story world
itself one thing I think is really
interesting that can help filmmakers
is really pay attention to what's going
on in video games so the video game
industry has made more money last year
than movies television and music
combined made 148 billion dollars
worldwide tremendous so - video games
are doing something that nobody else is
doing any of any other industry and if
you pay attention to how the video games
are promoting and getting people
interested in their IP you will see that
video games the the thing they push most
or story world's they will get you
interested in the story world itself
before anything else before they sell
you on mechanics before they sell you on
style before they sell you wants
individual story they the high concept
is always going to be attached to the
story world itself whether it's fallout
whether its death stranding whether it's
fortnight where it's a battle is it's a
crazy place for where people drop out of
a school bus into this like
ever-shrinking world that you can build
forts there's like whatever it is the
way they sell and the way they get
interest is because they're pushing for
forward story worlds that are
independently interesting beyond any one
character or one story and so I think
filmmakers can look at that now I don't
think you have to have a big budget to
have a good high concept story world
like again a high concept story world
isn't doesn't have to be Star Wars it
doesn't have to be Harry Potter like a
great high concept story world can exist
in a hundred thousand dollar feature
that like it doesn't change the way you
create an idea one of my favorite
stories about that is the purge purge is
a great high concept story world where
the per the purchase is dystopian
America where all crime is legal for
1224 hours whatever it is and that's a
story world logline it's easily
understandable has irony and in the line
itself
it gets interest into the world but when
you go watch the original purge movie
it's all set in a house they don't leave
the house and that's all you know you
talk to filmmakers and and and they'll
understand any
movie that never leaves the house mm
excuse me it's because a budget it's a
cost-saving mechanism to only have one
location so they had a very small budget
and they and so they couldn't go explore
this tremendous world that they that
they they had created right so what I
loved about that is is really what they
didn't do what they didn't do is say you
know what we have this really cool idea
for a world but we only have a very
small budget to make a movie so let's
just not let's just set aside our high
concept world and just make a movie
about bad guys try to kill people inside
of a house and we'll save our cool story
world concept for later when we have a
big budget what they did they said no no
we'll we'll create the world and and
then we'll execute inside a house
because that's all the budget we have
and then if that's successful then guess
what they did and the purge - they went
outside the house and being in exploring
the world so what happens is even if you
have a really high concept story world
idea but a small budget you can execute
in that small budget but then when you
go to create the second story and the
third story you now have a growth plan
and room to now grow organically inside
that world because if they were to come
out with the second movie and said oh
yeah by the way you can kill people for
one day and they added the high concept
the second time around
it would have been inauthentic and so
I'm very very much an advocate for
designing designing a 40,000 square foot
blueprint for a house and this large
story world that has independent
interest even if you can only build one
room because when you build the first
room what happens is if it works and
everything goes well you can go start to
build the second room and the third room
and now you have a growth plan for your
plumbing connects and your electrical
connects and everything like works well
as you grow out and then maybe you get
to a bigger room and a bigger room and a
bigger room where you can explore more
things so and if it doesn't work all
you've done is burnt one creative idea
and you should have a hundred more and
so so I think a great story world is
independent of budget but at the same
time communicate to the audience that
this is interesting
beyond just one story and if an audience
recognizes that guess who also
recognizes that it's a buyer
it's an investor right so so so savvy
buyers and savvy investors can they look
at certain projects now and they say
that's a great world because listen if
you sell something to the studio as an
independent writer you sell something to
a studio you're gonna get rewritten
anyway they're gonna put somebody on it
that that is sort of a you know a
tried-and-true studio writer it's gonna
rewrite your stuff anyway right so so
our studio if they identify a script
that has a great story world where they
know they can get 10 or 12 or a hundred
stories over the next 10 years across
seven different platforms the investment
they make into that script that has that
world is is a better investment than the
one off script that's going to be one
really good movie but doesn't give a
consideration to any store to a story
world aspect to it right so so the
studio is the network's and the
investors they're looking for market
potential and Story potential but your
story potential is directly linked to
the revenue potential which is also
directly linked to the story world
itself and so and so you actually you
actually position yourself for a for a
better chance of acquisition when you
have a story world that shows off the
revenue potential and the story
potential across platform even listen
even if you don't come up with all the
other stuff even if you don't say this
is the video game and this is the fit
this is the the Instagram thing if you
just have a tremendous world and sell
the world with the story savvy buyers
will recognize that potential for you
sometimes they think well this guy
doesn't even know what he has right and
and and so what we see now in the
industry it's really interesting the
past two years what's been going on is
that studios have been acquiring story
worlds without stories like you think
you I just have to have the independents
like the feature film script of the
whole thing not necessarily because
there's a lot of short films that have
been created
that don't have feature concept that
don't even have stories all they do is
have a story world concept that within a
week have created calls bidding wars
between the studios the studios want the
world they they have they have overall
deals with with writers and directors
and producers already that they can drop
in that world to write any script or
develop whatever what they need is the
IP and so tremendous stories is is
there's an artist the Scandinavia artist
named Simon Stalin Hogg and he creates
he's a painter and he creates these
paintings that are tremendous they all
they all have like dystopian sci-fi
story world elements Amazon approaches
approaches him and says we love this
story world you're creating in your
painting we want to make a TV show set
in this world
he sold us he sold a TV show to Amazon
without ever writing a pilot script
without even wanting to write because he
just created a tremendous world that
Amazon said that has potential and we
want to play in that sandbox right so
making sure you have a commercial idea
that is attached to the world itself
that is that's a tremendous thing also
think of beyond individual characters
understanding character groups and and
so I think that that is a smart tactical
way to develop story worlds you're not
thinking about Luke Skywalker you think
about Jedi you're not thinking about
Frodo you're thinking about the hobbits
right you don't think about Ironman
you're thinking about superheroes and
the because the more characters you have
more character groups you have you
increased story you increased story
potential and make your world a better
populated place with more interesting
people and I think adding in what I call
special sauce to your story road is
really important because a lot of
especially now it's very difficult to
come up with a story world idea that
hasn't been done it's completely unique
and so what I encourage a lot of a lot
of people to do is as they develop their
individual story worlds if they find
that their story world is similar to
other people's story worlds that's ok
what they need to do is just go in and
add three or four
new rules within the world a special
sauce that differentiates them from the
convention for example vampire story
worlds have been done forever Stephenie
Meyer said I'm still gonna do vampires
even though vampire story worlds have
been done forever but I'm gonna change
two or three rules within my vampire
story world I'm going instead of them
being soulless emotionless beasts my
vampires are gonna be super emo lovers
instead of them melting in the sunlight
they're gonna Sparkle right Ally she
just she changed like two or three rules
all of a sudden this story world in
Twilight feels fresh and new right like
wizard stuff have been it has been done
forever but JK Rowling made these
children wizards and and gave it a
little fresh twist that just made that
story world feel fresh and new and so so
find a way just to - if you're doing
zombies or if you're doing you know
something in space you're doing
something in like sword and sandal
fantasy figure out the one or two or
three rules that you can change within
that world that just makes it feel
different than Star Trek or Game of
Thrones or you know whatever else and
and if you add that special sauce the
little tweak to a world that has a
commercially interesting idea that's
rooted in the thematic then all of a
sudden you are light years ahead of any
creator that just is trying to write
like the one individual script you you
you are now on the way to creating a
really robust an interesting story world
when writing a story do you think it's
important to write the story around a
transmedia like structure or to extend
it to transmedia after you have already
developed a story so when you're
developed when you're developing stories
I think you have to you have to
understand that you have to execute this
single story by itself no matter what
other transmedia idea that you have I
think the tendency can be I get so
focused on all the all the stories
that that that I don't execute any
individual individual story the right
way and that that that's a mistake
because you have to understand if if if
your movie isn't good if your script
isn't good nothing works
if your if your TV pilot isn't good
nothing works
now what I would say is I'm a fan of of
developing the transmedia plan first and
and understand understanding how all the
stories interplay and understanding your
story world and understand and where the
opportunities are and then once you have
that sort of structure and that
architecture in play and you understand
where what part of the puzzle
this individual story is then then what
you do is just then set that aside you
sit all that aside and then you just got
dive in and make sure you write an
awesome script and an awesome pilot and
and execute that thing but when you when
you when you're writing it you will
naturally be building in new
opportunities you'll because you'll
understand how this interplays with the
other stories you understand more about
your story world and naturally you're
gonna start lacing things in that if you
hadn't done that work first you wouldn't
have which means then if you do all the
trends media opportunities after the
fact then one thing is gonna one or two
things gonna happen is you're probably
going to say oh I need to go rewrite my
script to be able to accommodate for all
these things but then it may not feel
natural or organic or you're gonna say
I'm just gonna leave it as it is and
then it feels disconnected and you're
not going to get the the the experience
that you want so so it's it's a balance
is is if you don't develop it as you're
writing I think you develop the plan the
broad plan from an IP perspective this
is my road map the you know if if you
know I'm gonna I'm gonna drive from LA
to New York and I'm gonna look at the
map and I see my route that I'm gonna
take this is the broad route that I'm
gonna take right and I map that and I
understand where I'm going I understand
how to get there but eventually I need
to get in the car and I'm not gonna be
like staring at the map the entire time
in the car I'm in the car and I'll make
minor adjustments as I'm in the car I'll
get off a certain rest stops I'll get a
maybe take a different road here or
there but I still already understand the
direction that I'm going the problem is
I think most people like jump in the car
and then you haven't a destination right
they say I'm just going to drive that
inch ends up being more work on the back
end me personally I hate to rewrite
I hate rewriting I think all writers
hate rewriting and so I want to minimize
my rewriting process as much as possible
which means then I think you you just
build you build in an IP design set that
aside
and then go I think that the balance of
that is sometimes tricky and you kind of
learn your way but I think that's the
best way forward that's very interesting
if you think about in the sense that
almost like what you're saying is that
it's better to design a world first and
then if you already have an idea for a
character to try to find a way to fit
your character into that world or
develop a character that works well into
the world rather than trying to design a
world that your character can go into so
like you have the world's first and then
you can then you can choose from a
plethora of different characters rather
than limiting yourself to a world with
the character that you've already
developed yeah yeah when it comes to a
lot of times people ask me do you
develop story first or story world's
first I'm a big advocate of developing
story world first it's not story world
or story its story world first then
story it's it's like I I liken it to
putting on your pants and putting her in
your shoes you need them both you need
pants and shoes you just put your pants
on before you put your shoes on right
that's that's just the that's the order
that's the best order if you put your
shoes on before you put your pants on
usually it's a more difficult you know
way to go and so if it sometimes you
have an idea of a character or have an
idea of a story already and then what
you want to do is just extract that
character instruct the story set them on
the shelf and then go ahead and develop
that story well then put
back in but if you can design an
independently interesting story world
that is beyond just a single character
beyond just a single story then you know
now that you the IP potential is is
optimized because the commercial 'ti is
attached to the world itself but because
if you do it the opposite way the
commercial 'ti and high-concept is going
to be attached to the the character and
that that is that makes it risky because
if people don't like that character or
in film and television if that actor
doesn't want to do the sequel or if you
know things like that like it all of a
sudden the the the potential of your IP
becomes very minimized and it's
dangerous to build around those
characters so I'm a big advocate of
story world first then story that
operates within that story world I think
that's where that's when you're going to
maximize that transmedia cross-platform
IP potential what suggestions do you
have for writers on developing character
so for me you know Hunger Games is no
good without caddis that you like you
like Katniss is the end harry potter is
the is the end like you have to have a
great hero or your products don't work
obviously it doesn't matter how good
your story world is doesn't matter how
good your your your plot is you have to
have a character that that people that
people care about and so when you know
you're you're you're talking about the
individual journey of the character and
how to develop the character I think
personally it goes back to subbox I
think it goes back to that thematic that
you're trying to to create and develop
and if you know what you want to say
then you will naturally know how to
develop your character and so because
typically your soapbox will be be
something that your character needs to
learn and if you know you you want to
teach people to how to how to you know
overcome disabilities and or or or you
know if you go back to the Joseph
Campbell thing about like you know
achieving or embracing your destiny
right so neo story the matrix for
example neo story is I
think his so box that message of if his
character goes from you know somebody
that that embraces their destiny and
they have this tremendous destiny that
they achieve that he achieves at the end
really interesting character development
happens there but his starting point is
him not him needing to find out the
soapbox is he he's at a place where he
he doesn't feel like he has any purpose
any death any great destiny at all he's
stuck in a cubicle has a meaningless
life and so his starting point there is
is a great starting point because if you
then when he achieves the soapbox at the
end of the movie that's what creates the
the development so I think you know any
any good screenwriter is going to tell
you when you develop a character its
cooled it I think adding a high concept
of that character I think it's cool to
you know make that character interesting
in a lot of different ways but if you
the emotional arc of the character needs
to be rooted and what are they learning
what what's their deficit at the
beginning and how do they realize that
soapbox toward the end and that's what
gives them the emotional journey and I
think if you tie that to that basically
that the a and B story right like you
have your your a story which is the
physical goal they're trying to achieve
so in taken the a story is all about how
I get my daughter back but then the B
story is is basically how do i how do i
become a good dad and it's sort of the
emotional deficit that he hasn't is is
that he has in the beginning is what he
learns toward the end of the movie and
so so it's tying those two things
together i think really makes the good
character development but but from a
transmedia perspective I think always
understanding how to give your
individual character a high concept and
also give them interesting looks and
this is something that like you can pull
from from George Lucas is that is that
Darth Vader would not be as iconic if he
was just a dude in a robe right like I
think there's something about the about
the look of Darth Vader that makes him
iconic Boba Fett you know characters
that have interesting dress interesting
objects that they have the the costume
design I think goes a
lot into what makes the character
interesting good the Black Panther I
think you know that like the female
warriors the way they were dressed the
way they looked I think that added so
much to the character and so there's a a
one of my one of my friends in the
transmedia community Jeffery long he he
always he always says that to have an
interesting character they need to have
an interesting silhouette and if the
more interesting their silhouette is
then the more striking and memorable
they'll be as a character and then you
know the more you do that then the more
yeah I think more story potential are
going to naturally have but I think that
you know the gas in the car when it
comes to character is what's their
emotional journey what's their physical
journey and you know course their
starting point how they how they end but
then if you could also layer in the high
concept to them and then add in like
sort of an interesting look with
interesting objects give them
interesting secrets that nobody else
knows I think the little things right
like that make characters awesome like I
love the fact that Indiana Jones is
scared of snakes like that's just a
really like small thing to add into the
character but super effective that gives
that that interesting character depth
though understanding like what are your
character is afraid of what's a secret
they've never told anybody doing that
sort of work then then even if you never
reveal those things in your first story
in a transmedia world those are things
that you can kind of pick on and use
this jumping off points moving forward
you know I used the movie um quiz show a
couple times I you've realized I'm going
back like alright twenty years but I
find that a very interesting look at two
characters sure one who's actually not
telling the truth but he's regarded as
the hero yeah and the other one who's
actually being honest and he's actually
in a tough situation is being like
henpecked and told he has to make more
money but he's actually painted as a
villain sure and I just think it's a
very fine it's based on a loosely based
on true story but maybe talk about the
like what why are we perceiving Ralph
Fiennes his character as really the hero
this guy gets an applause from the
subcommittee or whatever and he's like
praise as this golden boy and John
Turturro is actually the bad guy yeah I
I think this is really interesting just
I think that is a commentary on culture
of how we root for for certain
characters or don't root for
characters me I always the the a great
example of that is I think is Breaking
Bad of you know that Walt is doing bad
things even after he passes the point
like at first you justified is like he's
doing it for good reasons but then like
everybody kind of gets the fact that
he's that he's doing it he's Breaking
Bad right and that's the whole point of
it but we're still rooting for Walt the
intent like we're still rooting for well
one of the most derided like hated
characters on that show was his wife my
people I people didn't like his wife and
she like you know she was a good person
that wanted to do good things and and so
she was the good guy Walt's the bad guy
but the way we the way we cheer for them
is is is is flip-flopped right I've
forced Whitaker was I heard an interview
with him when he starred on the shield
if you remember the shield Allen FX and
Vic Mackey was the greatest TV
characters of all time he's a bad guy
he's straight-up a bad guy but he's the
protagonist and and we root for him the
entire time Forest Whitaker is the is
the cop who comes to investigate him
he's the good guy we we hate that guy
we hate the character and and it's just
we flip-flop going back to an old Johnny
Cash interview that I heard is he would
talk about how how when he was seeing
Folsom Prison Blues whatever he would
whenever he would deliver the line I
shot a man in Reno just to watch him die
crowds would roar and they they loved
that line and and you're thinking why
would they like that like why did they
get excited about this character that
Johnny Cash is portraying shooting a man
just to watch him die this is a
despicable awful evil thing but I feel
like that's a testament to culture me
even in professional wrestling circles
right I mean if you take it to that like
Stone Cold Steve Austin was a bad guy
that people loved because he was
breaking the rules I think it's just an
interesting commentary on people and how
we
we lean in to to sort of the bad boy bad
girl we lean into those I mean I think I
think if you look at even the superhero
stuff today culture there was a day
where Batman and Superman were the
square-jawed wholesome John Wayne type
of heroes and superheroes today now we
love Deadpool and I think that's just a
commentary on culture and and how
culture shifts over time and you know
there was a time when the John Wayne war
movie was ruled the box office but then
in the Vietnam era like that begin to
turn to where we didn't want the square
jawed like you know son going down to
the background and like the birds flying
around and at the patriotic music we
didn't want that anymore we wanted
something else and I think I think
that's just a testament to culture and
testament to like the human condition
and the human like the the human
condition of the condition of the soul
of the audience is is and I think you
know we're trained as far as story we're
trained if you position someone as a
protagonist whether they're antihero
protagonist whatever they're so you you
almost remove the the hero villain
moniker if a great storyteller positions
a bad guy as a protagonist we just will
naturally root for them I mean if for
example in Star Wars they're like lines
of comic books that where Darth Vader is
the protagonist and you're rooting for
them him the entire time and he's a
mass-murdering magician and and you
still root for the guy because we're
trained to root for protagonist I think
that's just like hardwired into our
brains to where it makes perspective and
POV really super important important to
a storyteller understanding that because
naturally we root for the protagonist
whether or not or despite the fact that
they're good or maybe they're bad so as
we've been talking about transmedia and
you know this idea of like trying to
pull a bunch of stories from our story
world where do you look to to try and
craft that many stories out of one story
world
what kind of like techniques to use to
to pull good stories out for all these
different platforms across your story
room so people can get the theory and
they can get excited about the model but
practically what are the strategies to
use to be able to identify jumping-off
points in story that maximises the
transmedia model there's a couple ways
that I think are very easy to identify
and one of them is unanswered questions
and so I think this is the easiest way
to create transmedia opportunities is
identify unanswered questions in your
script and in a movie in a TV show
whatever it is unanswered questions and
then answer them somewhere else in a
different platform you know for example
like in you know take the the classic
example of Pulp Fiction what's in the
briefcase and if they if they didn't
answer in the film which I think was
right for the film kind of created a
mystique around the film but if if today
Tarantino launched a web series or a
comic book series or novel or something
that was all about the briefcase and the
guys to go get the briefcase and what's
and actually reveals what's in the
briefcase
all of a sudden like that's a tremendous
incentive for me as a fan of Pulp
Fiction to go check that out in in
Inception where you don't know at the
end whether he's stuck in the dream or
not stuck in the dream because he spins
the top and they cut the film that's not
notice or question and so if they if
they answer that somewhere else in an
app or a song or something then that's a
transmedia opportunity I like to think
back to the the Sofia Coppola first film
lost in translation at the end Bill
Murray whispers something into her ear
and you don't know what he says and
that's an answer question and if 20
years or 10 years later however long
that films been out if they reengage the
audience by you know whether it's a love
song that reveals the line what maybe
it's an email that Bill Murray's
character sends scholar Johansson's
character that the audience is cc'd on
that you get in your and remember that
time I've whispered this into your ear
in Tokyo that all of a sudden is
valuable for the audience so if
go through a script and and you you can
readily identify transmedia
opportunities that that you may didn't
didn't know from the beginning of you
know where did that character go when
she went off screen why does he have a
black eye with what's behind that door
where does that car go what are these
guys talking about like like unanswered
questions you can probably find 15 in in
a in an existing script or pilot already
that then is then transmitted
opportunity that you can split off in
answer somewhere else or if you're
creating a writing a script from you
know square one with this knowledge you
will naturally build in questions that
you know you're not going to answer
until you release this other thing in a
different platform and so you know a
great example that is is when in in the
force awakens in Star Wars
c-3po has a red arm and nobody knows why
c-3po has a red arm it's an unanswered
question
well then Lucasfilm released a comic
book a one-shot comic book about c-3po
and how he got the red arm it's such a
simple stupid thing that that isn't like
it's not rocket science it's like
literally play on the curiosity of
people pose a question don't answer it
answer it somewhere else
it's like ready-made transmedia in a box
JJ Abrams calls it mystery box right
he's so according this tower mystery box
of like the the human mind will always
want answers to questions and and if you
just build in intentionally questions
that you don't answer in your script
answer them somewhere else maybe not
immediately maybe wait 10 years and wait
until what you feel like your audience
is starting to like wane and die off and
this is a way to reengage them in a
great way in music you have Michael
Jackson this is Billie Jean is not my
lover she's just a girl who says that
that I am the one the kid is not my son
the unanswered question is is Michael
the dad of this kid or isn't he he says
he's not we don't know to answer
question so if today they released
something that that revealed whether
Michael was the father of that kid I
would absolute
they check that out for sure right the
old day you know I'd like to use the
example of like with my my early college
days when the Baja man had that song
called who let the dogs out and right
they that if if today the Baja men
tweeted out come check out my new album
I would never click that link I don't
listen to the Baja man but if they if
they if they said hey click this link
and actually find out who let the dogs
out I would I would do that of course I
would do that and it's just a click
right and then if they pay it off by
going to the website and find an out
stoop dog let the dogs out and now
there's a new collaboration on the new
album or whatever all of a sudden they
got me to the website but they got me by
playing on the the curiosity of I always
wonder who look what the answer to that
question is so that's a great
opportunity for transmedia I think
character backstory is a great
opportunity for transmedia we you know
screenwriters deal with this all the
time how much backstory the characters
can we put in a script the more you
explore backwards the less you're going
forwards and it's always just this push
and pull in a script because you only
have 110 pages and a feature etcetera
etcetera so so if you understand the
transmedia model this is a tremendous
tool for riders to say I can still tell
my back story without overburdening or
encumbering my feature script or my TV
pilot I'm just gonna tell the back story
somewhere else in a different platform
so maybe I have my feature script maybe
I have a short story that's the
character backstory maybe have a song
maybe I have an animated short film that
works as the backstory over watch the
video game over watch the the video the
video games the first-person shooter and
they don't tell you any story about any
of your characters on their website they
have the backstory of all their
characters in animated short films that
are tremendous storytelling tools so
they get the backstory but they get it
without overburdening or encumbering
their video game so they basically have
their cake and they eat it too AMC does
this all the time though for all the
characters and all their shows on the
AMC website they'll launch launched
digital comics that explore the
backstory of all their characters which
is extended content for the fans but but
for creators is great
because we get the things that we love
we get the backstory that we love but at
the same time we get a tight efficient
script or TV show or movie that isn't
encumbered so that's another really
super easy way different X like
different parts of the story world that
you can explore if you never show what's
what's in the basement of this house
then all of a sudden a short story or a
poem or a piece of art that that shows
what's in the basement valuable
comprehension things like that there are
practical ways to approach transmedia
strategy that aren't that hard that that
aren't you know rocket scientist
type of things to figure out deleted
scenes I'm always a big fan of deleted
scenes of them not just dying on a DVD
special feature or or you know there's
always scenes that we screenwriters have
to cut out that we can't use because
we're trying to come in at page length
and so I'm always an advocate if not not
deleting but cutting and pasting and you
can take the scenes that you cut from a
script or cut from a book or a chapter
that you removed from a book or a verse
that you removed from a song and just
figuring out how to repurpose that into
into a different medium or different
platform then it's already made
transmedia opportunity that's already
written then then maybe you figure out
how to how to you know turn that into an
illustrated thing or maybe maybe
communicate it through you know whatever
it is a digital platform make it a VR
opportunity or communicate it through
augmented reality something like that I
think would be interesting so if you had
just imagine if you had scenes that were
cut out of Reservoir Dogs or Pulp
Fiction or something like this and then
there was a mug that you could buy that
was a Pulp Fiction mug or a Reservoir
Dogs mug that you had an augmented
reality app that you could hold up to
the mug and all of a sudden you you you
you can read or experience the the scene
that was cut out of the film 20 years
earlier that's awesome I would love that
as a fan I would love that and then and
then as a fan if you know fans would
love that then why don't you do that
you're wasting those scenes anyway right
so identifying that narrative excess
unanswered questions further story world
exploration and character backstories
all great ways to have like ready-made
in the
transmedia strategy how do you feel
about the quote never let your technique
show I mean I think it's a good quote I
mean I think I think that is I think the
I think skillful people skillful people
at their craft know how to do that well
I think I for example I think story
structure is great I'm a big story
structure nerd I love I love McKee and
Syd field and Blake Snyder and all those
guys I love all that we're story
structure I think gets a bad rap is when
people use story structure but they're
not good enough to cover it up and and
then it like they let the they like the
techniques show the great writers though
I think use the structure and then
they're good enough to weave such a
tapestry around that structure that it's
structured but you don't care you don't
realize it's there that's where I think
the sweet spot is and so in that regards
I'm 100% in agreeance not to let the
technique show i mean if it's like for
me it's it's you know if you stripped
all everybody down to the bones all of
your skeletons will look pretty similar
but it but the thing that makes us all
unique is when you guys start layering
in you know all the different aspects of
how we look even to the way we dress
right once we add in all that stuff now
we're all super unique and super
different and super interesting and that
that I think is what makes us individual
people and so so people that let the
technique show are I think I think
struggle with struggle with executing in
such a way to like to bury it under
their creative eye
I think people take that quote though to
mean that technique isn't good like
technique is somehow a bad thing that
technique is somehow this like
restrictive pejorative sort of a of a
thing whether it's story structure
whatever it is I think technique gets a
bad rap in that way so I'm a
huge advocate for strategy and technique
but the great creators and this is where
the art comes in is the art comes in is
how do you use the technique and use the
structure and then layer on top of that
so much creativity and such amazing
ideas that people don't see it though
it's always there if somebody left a
funny comment on one of our videos and
they said oh yeah you you're Tecna
you're your structures great and you
have the inciting incident on this but
just your script is horrible but it's -
hey great structure you know I mean
essentially kind of making fun of the
fact that yeah if you don't have a great
story then all of that is wasted sure
matter it's it's it's you entertainment
is not paint-by-numbers and that's and
that's the variable that will always be
the variable is that whether it's Blake
Snyder or Syd field or Robert McKee or
whether you're doing super story
transmedia stuff like you can have it
all mapped out but the great variable is
are you good enough to execute and
because yeah technically you're inciting
innocent can be here and you're your act
to Turning Point is here and you know
the dark night of the soul was here and
it's all placed very well but but if you
can't if you can't execute in a way that
makes people forget about the technique
then then it I think is just a
reflection on your talent or you maybe
just think there rewrite maybe you just
you need to take some more time with it
to be able to show your talent that
being said I think technique is
necessary sure and and so I think a lot
of times people throw throw the baby out
with the bathwater so to speak and
saying well you know story structure
that's that we don't need that it
doesn't matter where your inciting
incident is it doesn't matter if you
have three acts
you know Xterra cetera i'm i don't go
that far at all i think that stuff is
necessary you just got to be good enough
to make people forget about it so we're
a few months away from the final season
of Game of Thrones I was wondering if
you could see into your crystal ball and
see what their prediction will be for
the final six episodes oh man that is
such that is such a large question I
think if
what's interesting at this point is they
is they've passed the books so so george
RR martin isn't completely driving the
ship yet if george RR martin if we're
still operating in the George RR
Martin's level I would say everyone
would die I think now I feel like since
they passed the books they've kind of
clicked in to a little bit more of a
commercial like commercially
understandable type of a story which
means we're not gonna kill everyone we
love and so but at the same time I think
they're definitely going to surprise you
it would it would be me I definitely
think I mean obviously you know I think
you know Jon Snow and and you know
Daenerys
I don't see them long term I don't see
them serve both surviving I think it's
gonna be too easy for Daenerys to get
the throne I don't think they'll do that
because if I think they were going to
try to surprise us with something
different I think that I think somebody
will get the throne that you don't
expect whether it's Tyrion whether it's
Sansa something like that will happen
which I think will be unexpected but if
but I think jon snow dies i my my
instinct is is that he dies I don't know
I mean it's just like they've they've
left it in such a such a wide open space
that I don't know exactly where they're
going with it I'm notoriously bad for
predicting things like this and but they
both what got me excited yeah I read
recently that they that they're there
the battle this sort of a big battle
that they have at the end of the season
they shot for 58 days straight just to
do one battle which makes me more
excited that I've never imagined so so
whatever it's gonna be it's gonna be
awesome I I think I think I don't think
the White Walkers win I think we're safe
I think I'm safe to say that I think we
beat back the White Walkers in a way
that's that's unexpected but I still
think the White Walkers lose and then I
think how do they pick up the pee
with the seven kingdoms I'm gonna go
with the dark horse
Sansa gets the Iron Throne with Arya as
her hand with with either John or
Daenerys dying maybe even both so this
these are my words not yours but are
they selling out then if they've gone
past the books and you say that george
RR martin is not fully driving the the
metaphorical ship sure how they sold out
I don't think so I mean like listen I
think if you can make people happy that
is the greatest achievement of an
entertainer like whatever whatever it is
is is there's this competition between
like between I can either make people
happy or preserve my artistic integrity
I think if that is what you're trying to
decide between there's something wrong
because the point of art is to have
people experience it in an amazing way
that the whole the whole thing is about
not just how do I create create
something how do I create something that
makes other people happy excited how do
I beat people cry how do I make people
feel
that's the point and so if you make
something that people love and they
cheer and they're excited about and like
that's not selling out that's the point
of entertainment you've entertained them
in a way that they're happy I think
doing stuff like The Sopranos cutting
off the end and and it pisses everybody
off I am NOT a fan of that like I get
like sort of the we're gonna let you
finish the story in your mind that whole
thing I get I get all that but but at
the same time I look at I look at
entertainment very similar to
entrepreneurship like you you you were
you were there to serve something to
your fans that that gives them a
tremendous experience and if they walk
away pissed off and angry then you've
done something wrong not to say they
shouldn't walk away challenged I'm a big
fan of like challenging your fan base I
think that's what the last jet I did I
think the last bait the last Jedi
challenged the Star Wars fan base in a
good way
but but I think if they if I think
they'll go and they'll surprise people I
think I think but at the same time I
don't think they're gonna do something
weird to where you know they they make
it ambiguous I think it's going to be
clear I don't think it's gonna be left
up to interpretation I don't think it's
gonna be you know something unsatisfying
and awful that's gonna like piss
everybody off like Joffrey comes back as
a white Walker and sits on the throne
for the rest of like eternity as like
evil King Joffrey the dead I think that
would just piss everybody off I don't
think they're gonna do anything at that
but at the same time I think you're
gonna do something unexpected so you
know I don't know like I'm all about
Samwell Tarly taking the Iron Throne oh
that's cool or maybe they make the Iron
Throne insignificant you know even that
I think that would maybe thematically be
interesting because I think the sort of
the soap box of the guy of the of Game
of Thrones is all about
hey as we bicker over here amongst
ourselves there's something come to kill
us coming to kill us all and so we need
to unite and and and and you know stand
against that in that respect eventually
if like the game of throw the actual
iron throne becomes of zero importance
somatically may be interesting to where
we now you know there's not one country
or not one place that rules the Seven
Kingdoms it's a different sort of a
setup I don't think they'll do that
because I think they only have six
episodes that's like a big restructuring
of the story world but I'm for Samwell
Tarly surviving I'm four I think are I
think I think Arya well I think Arya
will finish her list I think that Jamie
is gonna kill Cersei and I think I don't
think Jon and Daenerys both survive I
want to pick one or the other and I
think Sonde's it for the Iron Throne
that's my lock in Super Bowl prediction